yeah so it was like an auto jacket they
would hold handles and you would it
would Jack Hammer your off right and
then the Tweet was woman be careful or
something at that point you got to be
like how far is too far man you know
what I uh I respect
that hello and welcome to the final
episode of
2023 congratulations on making it to the
end of the year we made it guys you
survived another year we survived I'm
impressed you somehow managed to bring
my fridge to the office this is really
impr you know when we ask staff to get
us drinks because it's an end of year uh
episode I wasn't expecting like
everything like we were going to have a
party for 10 it's a company card you
know right we gave them the company card
and they're like wait I can buy how many
Dr we going to start with a
non-alcoholic first before I jump right
starting off with non-alcoholic to start
with a non-alcoholic starting off with
non-alcoholic it's harder to go back
when I'm going to have a I'm going to
start with an alcoholic and then if I
feel like going non-alcoholic I'll go
nonalc I'm being judged okay fine you
successfully peered pre yes let's go
fine it's the end of year right it's
it's that ASMR it's the end of the year
although to be fair to be fair credit
credits to you cheers cheers Che ever
since uh our last conversation about
non-alcoholic beer I have been a conver
converted you yeah bro I'm telling it's
actually fire like Japan has Japan has
really been stepping up with the
non-alcoholic options and um to the
point now where you know if it's a night
where I'm going to have like one or two
beers yeah I'll just stay with the
non-alcoholics I'm like what's the point
I don't know I haven't got to the point
where I can just drink beer for The
Taste yet I [__] love the taste of
beer it's it's it's not I don't like
alcohol I like the taste of beer but not
enough to justify see it's not just
about the taste because I I remember
last time when I we had this
conversation I made the argument that
you know it just doesn't taste the same
which it doesn't but for me it's the
feeling of having a pint yeah you know
that's that's what I'm saying you you
laugh at it you said stop
do you know what it is I'm saying that
you know do you know what it is it's
it's not even the taste it's the it's
the foaminess of it you know it's it's
it's the gassiness that you only get
with uh kind of like beer drink some
[__] mineral water bro no I actually
do and I just doesn't hit the same if
you ever get into beer right like there
is this ultimate moment of peak
refreshness when you've had a day that
you felt like [__] that took it out of
me you crack that cat open and you take
that first sip full foam full coldness
it's every every Peak moment of the beer
and you're like yeah but I'm happy to
know that like taking that first sip
which I totally get is the best feeling
ever especially when it's like stupid
stinking hot in a Japanese summer right
like that that first ice cold can of
beer is the best but I also like the
fact that oh I'm going to get a little
bit loopy from it as well you know well
it's sometimes I don't know if I don't
want to get drunk I'll just crack open a
mineral I normally don't get drunk
though only maintain like the nice Buzz
level which beer helps me do wa what's
wrong with that though well no that's
not drunk though I wouldn't say it's
drunk it's just me being like a little
funny and a time do you not like getting
buzzed h no I like getting buzzed yeah
yeah yeah that's fun but so I'm trying
to figure out what's what's the
justification nonalcoholic well because
I don't always want to get that I I I I
think I do it a little bit different
from Connor because for me sometimes I
mean this goes back to I guess when I
was working the office job as well
sometimes you just have a really [__]
hard day of work sure and you just want
to sit back relax and crack open a cold
one just said
that I literally just said that no
because he he was he was saying about
the taste right for me well it's like
that's part of the experience there as
well to me like the taste you know but
it's mainly about Jesus you've had one
sip J it's mainly about like having the
long day and then getting that like
first Sip and it's like a very nice
feeling and beer has a texture which is
important in food uh it's a te very nice
texture that kind of just is I don't
know it's perfect I don't know no to
expand on what you were saying like
before um it's the feeling and also
sometimes you just want to crack open a
pint after a hard day of work without
needing to get like the consequence of
getting drunk or but do you feel the
consequences after one pint well no okay
so this is a great this is a great great
argument um that uh because I'm I'm
ready uh a be like this beer would be
like 250 calories or 200 calories right
okay not that I'm counting calories
right but I'm you know I want to be in
shape right so I'm I'm thinking to
myself what I can kind of roughly eat I
don't count calories to the [__]
number but I'm thinking in my head of
like the rough toll what I've been
eating sure and so if I have like two
beers or you know that's like a a full
like small lunch or a snack that I could
have eaten instead um they call beers
liquid meals for a reason yeah I mean
it's it's definitely the cobs are
killing man there so many cobs
especially if you're doing it Weekly
right cuz if you have one beer like four
times a week I have a solution then
that's like 1 th calories I have a
solution uh don't drink beer but I I
don't get the same refreshment and
enjoyment from like a m you got to
sacrifice one or the other well that's
why I I I we're sacrificing the alcohol
is the worst thing you could be
sacrificing wait it's The what
fically the best thing you can don't
sacrifice the [__] caffeine in a
coffee do you I wouldn't mind doing that
oh my God he's too far gone bro oh you
getting into deaf now he's too far gone
bro the reason why we've lost him the
reason why I'm never going to get into
decaf and this is a very piss poor
reason but I think it's valid yeah you
know I've got a I've got a coffee
machine and it takes a bunch of beans if
I I would have to like take out I would
have to take out all the beans and
replace them every time I want decaf I I
can't hear you say beans without hearing
you say beans what the
[__] I don't want to I don't want to
[__] have to change the entire
[__] machine drink decaf but well
that's what you get for having a [__]
off [__] off large machine uh yeah but
it's a beautiful machine it's the it's
the centerpiece of my
house you have what a [__] Lego piece
on your wall I've got a beautiful
Italian engineered espresso machine all
the engineering points of Italy went
into coffee they they can't make
anything else in Italy literally they
they don't have anything else but they
have is crying
right in like engineering wise right
Germany they they did it everything ity
was like well um espresso machines
anyone can't even build a [__] Tower
correctly man no
they just like what the [__] man have
you ever seen a completed Italian Road
Works doesn't
exist how's your [__] cities going oh
they're sinking oh okay that's good to
know Italy has like every single
economic crisis possible right now but
my God they still make a mean espresso
machine and the food [__] slaps the
food is amazing um point being so yeah
they they kind of spec their points to
the correct categories no it's fine
honestly I'm sure it looks lovely I
didn't mean to machine it's all right I
I took that personally oh sorry I'm all
sorry no but because of the
non-alcoholic beit I was like I saw
there was a store selling non-alcoholic
wine as well well and as you know I'm a
big I think that's called grape juice
and I was like I know this is going to
be grape juice but maybe because this
cuz I've realized n Al non-alcoholic
beer is basically just hop flavored
sparkling water so maybe they've just
made kind of like cuz wine is grape
juice obviously but it doesn't always
taste like grape juice you know yeah it
tastes like wine LS of aspects to yeah
yeah so maybe they made water taste like
beer without having the alcohol in it
maybe they've done the same with wine I
just bought [__] grape juice but they
marked it up to like $15 you just bought
expensive grap ju just bought really
[__] expensive grape juice I've never
been more disappointed in my life this
is what's wrong with Society I got
invited out to this extremely fancy
restaurant and I it was an Italian
restaurant and I was like you know I I
love Italian food but this was like gig
bougie fusion and when I hear Fusion
food in my head I'm like okay so they
just going to [__] it up
um cuz pasta you know pasta is just
pasta you know what I mean like I feel
like Fusion's coming back I think some
fusion works but Italian is one of those
things where I'm like actually don't
Fusion it they actually figured it out
please stop messing with it the it's
because the word Fusion was just ruined
by all of these restaurants that just
use the word Fusion just to say that
they want yeah that's just say serve
every kind of southe St you know I went
to this Thai Japanese fusion and I
thought that was great because that was
literally just adding spices to Japanese
food because in Japan it's it's all just
salt which is fine but they added like
spiciness to it I was like wait this is
like you guys should do this like this
is this is great but I went to the time
when it was very good but the reason I
bring this up is because they had a
non-alcoholic wine pairing menu and I
didn't want to drink that day so I was
like okay sure I'll try it um and and to
be fair to their credit I don't even
want to know how much it would cost I
didn't pay um that's why you did it um
there was no prices on the menu which
meant everything I didn't even want to
know everything came out and it was this
big which I think goes against the
entire point of Italian food I'm
supposed to I'm supposed to feel
morbidly obese after going to an Italian
that's the American side of you uh well
no I just think Italian food you should
feel very full like it's it's a very
well you do cuz a lot of it is very cly
that's that's the fusion part of it the
Fus and the fusion they they fusioned
all the food away because each pesta was
like this and the guy brought it out and
I said where's the rest of it think that
the guy couldn't speak English and he
goes what and I said ah nothing nothing
anyway they brought this this fusioned
it with nothing single dish came with a
non-alcoholic wine pairing thing and
they were like it was like Jasmine uh
one of them was like Jasmine flower
petals with something it was yeah and it
was kind of okay I I felt like it was
good enough that for a meal I would be I
would be like yeah that's close enough
but it was missing the core feeling of
wine whereas I think non-alcohol
non-alcoholic beer has kind of gotten
the the core feeling of beer question
would you if you had if you were paying
for that restaurant experience would you
have gotten that non-alcoholic
why oh did you did you do it because you
seized the opportunity of getting it
trying it out like free of charge it was
just super fancy juice that was slightly
viscous and like which is fine CU I
think that like that that that's also
like an option I think that like I think
any anytime you can present an option
that doesn't have alcohol we should be
encouraging that because obviously the
less alcohol we all drink the better um
so if if you can get it like if wine
tasted the exact same but with no
alcohol bro I'm I'm all there you know
what I mean yeah you can't say that in
front of a [__] sea of alcohol but
that's the thing I maybe maybe in 60
years you know uh Connor junor will be
able to enjoy all the flavors of
non-alcoholic beer without needing to
drink alcohol look look I'm not calling
him Junior by here's the thing for the
here's the problem okay I like getting
drunk sure I don't like the consequence
of getting drunk you know that's that's
something that you did not have to deal
with in your 20s and then you grow up
and then you realize wait there are
consequences for the stupid action that
I take and it's unfortunate that Japan
is a very very alcoholic country yeah we
love to drink well so is England and so
is Australia and I thought England was
pretty England and the UK was bad in
general you know and I felt that in the
UK it was more so I would drink on
weekends and I would drink hard on the
weekends yeah but in Japan I what I
found is is that you drink hard but
it'll be a Tuesday and then a a Thursday
and then a Friday and a Saturday and
you're like okay hold up now I'm
doubling what I was doing before reality
really doesn't slap you in the face here
until you witness should be a meltdown
for with your own eyes you know there is
just so much more casual alcohol
consumption here and to more of an
extent than so much cheaper as well yeah
like it's so cheap eat out way more here
as well so it's totally like if you're
in England you if you go out um if you
just casually go to a pub then you
probably an alcoholic you know
but or a brexit Geer or or brex of Gea
like if you just casually go to the pub
on most week days you're probably an
alcoholic how we may how we like coped
with that was we were like we just drink
on the weekends we guys what alcohol we
just drink on the weekend that's how we
cope with it I think that as a human
being you are entitled to
self-destruction um as long as you're
not hurting anyone else if you want to
drink on the weekends and that's your
thing [__] do it if if it's affecting
other people then you got to [__]
address it yeah and then like that was
before I started Workforce and then when
I entered the workforce it's it slowly
started to creep in to be like today was
a hard day of work and some of my
co-work like the dangerous that's where
like the line like between uh my first
example and my second example that's how
you tiptoe the line um so I kind of
realized the sad realization that stuff
like this helps us [__] tiptoe that
line right it is nice I mean it's yeah I
have a feeling though that you guys have
kind of reached this point probably
because you both of you drink more often
than I
do% I don't drink at home I I don't
think I've drank in like over a week at
least for me and like I only maybe drink
like two or three times a month so I
feel like the more you drink the more I
might start to feel like this month this
month particularly is generally a bad
one this one this month is oh don't
worry next week I'm in Australia I'm not
going to have a sober day well yeah it's
like when my when my brother was here
you know it's his vacation right so when
I'm out with him he wants to drink and I
you know I'm like yeah [__] it I'll
drink with my brother I don't get to see
you that much the problem is that when
you think about times like that you're
like okay my brother is here he's here
for like one week every [__] 3 years
or something
I'm going to commit to that but the is
that okay maybe the week before that I
also just happened to drink a lot and
then now I'm drinking all week and maybe
I drink a little bit next week too so it
ends up being like it doesn't matter
what the circumstances the facts are is
that maybe I just drank a bunch this day
and then I'm just trying to battle that
is uh yeah was just
ound slowly starting sound to sound like
alcohol like Anonymous or right but this
is what happens when I realized I was
like the consequences of having a social
life in Japan cuz Japan social life
equals drink but I mean you know I
lately I've just been saying like you
know if I know it's going to be like CU
some people just invite you out for a
casual dinner and I'm like chill [__]
yeah I'll drink and I'm like actually no
I'm just I'm just going to [__] drink
tea [__] this I just to me I'm like if
I'm not going to have like four beers
I'm like yeah I [__] but we also like
I feel like Japanese culture as well is
uh is an interesting one because even
though we drink so much like casually
regardless of the day of the week we're
also more forgiving to those who don't
want to drink or can't drink just
because I feel there's a lot more people
who just cannot drink MH right it's it's
it's very odd CU I it depends on the
person though as well i' I've definitely
met Japanese people that are like you
don't want to drink what yeah that to
them I'd be like [__] off it's my choice
stop judging me whereas in Australia
like if you couldn't drink like you were
you know in some ways judged and I'm
sure the same in the UK as well right
because like drinking culture is such a
normal culture over there that when you
see someone who can't drink or doesn't
want to drink then it's kind of like why
wish Muslims must have been watching
this first half of the show being like
what are they talking what are they what
are they talking about that sounds like
some funny juice that they're drinking
right now devil yeah because like I
every time it always kind of like makes
me realize whenever I talk to an
American and so many Americans I know it
depends on obviously which state you're
from but so many Americans I know don't
know the difference I like I've had to
explain the difference between going out
and going out out if if if you guys get
what I mean like going out like the
first one just being like oh we're just
GNA go maybe have a couple of yeah just
like a casual drink casual time not
drunk and then there's going out yeah
yeah so sometimes sometimes to explain
sometimes you go out with your mates to
the to the PB or something and you just
have a casual some casual drinks and on
some special occasions maybe the vibe is
just right you have you start getting to
that zone where you're like should we
should we go out out are we going to are
we going to go out out this is a UK
specific problem though cuz often like
if you have to like kind of pregame yeah
normally that means like okay well
there's this this this this pivotal
decision moment yeah where people are
going to decide let's keep going or
let's go for but in Japan I feel like
it's such those lines are so blurred CU
you're always out in Japan yeah so
you're always close to the next place or
the next bar you know one thing that I
like about Japan culture what they don't
really have a shot culture here oh thank
[__] for
that if you drink with Pete Pete finds
the places with the shot culture well
he's American though yeah I know but he
just you know he's he's too charismatic
the bar owners involved and they're like
you should drink more you need to go to
those like specific establishments
though right but you know what sucks is
that when I tell people they're like
like how how did you how did you learn
most of Japanese I'm like [__] I hate to
admit it but like just going out and
drinking was most of it for me honestly
that is going These Bars and talking to
Bar owners you know and they're so
welcoming especially if you're a if
you're a foreigner who speaks uh some
Japanese they you know they and they can
kind of see that that that normally that
huge barrier is kind of gone there's
normally this kind of curiosity that
kind of opens up where you can really
just have a really good conversation
because they want to talk to you and you
want to talk to them cuz you're you know
you're at their bar and you want to get
to know the the places cuz I think
everyone everyone has that like
especially if you're going to a place
somewhat often you always want to be
like does that guy remember me like I
want to be I want to be like this guy
he's like yeah it's this guy again you
know because you want to it's like
almost like a sense of community right
because inan you don't you don't get
that in a lot of places if I went to the
same you're the local gion at this far
but like if I went to the same like uh
grocery store for like two years in a
row in the UK there's a solid chance at
least in Wales if it's a smaller one if
it's a supermarket probably not but if
it's like a smaller one right odds are
you'll the staff will probably remember
you or they'll probably say oh hi how
you doing you know you have that little
bit of conversation just kind of like
that that you don't realize how much it
kind of like gives you a bit of like oh
man that's nice and the only place you
can really get this in Japan is bars
because like comini they ain't going to
[__] it you can go to the comini 5
million times and they're never going to
be say anything to you it's not going to
happen store no I've been recognized by
a number of colini well okay but is that
is that I I I got to go I got to you got
to go I got I got to hook
up that's an anomaly right that's like
not normal right so in in Japan like if
you want to get like that kind of
friendly sense of like almost like
almost like a missing sense of community
well I think it also doesn't help that
like we are in like the biggest city in
the [__] world other cities on Earth
don't do this I noticed London was
different like London I know if I went
to the same place over and over again I
would kind of get that familiar
connection but but that's because
they're more have more of that stranger
friendliness right like in Tokyo that
stranger friendliness is close to zero
especially between a Japanese person and
a g Tokyo is such a lonely place and it
has this reputation rightfully so for
being one of the lonliest cities despite
being a [__] giant City uh because
there is that like there like zero sense
of community in a lot places yeah like
walking into like any kind of store in
Tokyo is like just the same interaction
over and over it's like it's like
entering the item shop in an RPG you
know you're going to get the same
dialogue every single time even if
you've been in their 100 times yeah but
you know I like that in Japan you can
still get that but it's main at bars
it's kind of nice cuz I got a bunch of
bars that I go to where they're always
like oh how you doing man you doing well
well I feel like it's kind of their job
to be social right or at least more
Social cuz I think they realize that
that's also a good business move right
get repeaters coming back right or at
least if you were a good me I mean it's
it's makes a lot of places that I um
I've noticed they are just genuinely
nice genuinely nice and just genuinely
enjoy the company and enjoy the
conversation and they are genuinely
curious also like to say earlier when I
say I got a girl I was [__] being
sarcastic it's like an old elderly
Japanese woman um so you got a girl I
got a girl you got a girl she's still a
girl I was like I I and she works like
okay so there's this old elderly
Japanese woman and she normally works
The Late Shift uh so I normally hit the
comy after like a trash taste recording
or something and there was this one time
where I went in it was really late after
a night out uh and there was this
Foreigner there and she was trying to
explain some uh she was trying to
explain uh explain how to use like the
card system and stuff like that and he
just wasn't [__] allow totr and she
was she was
like and she was like can you explain to
this person what I'm saying and I was
like all right I got this i got this um
and uh yeah so I translated I translated
what she was saying to him to explain
how to use the machine he was trying to
use uh and then ever since then she's
just like she's just been like extra
like friendly and happy every time we
come in I'm like all right I got to go
now that's what's up I got to go now so
next time you go in you'll be like hey
yo can I have some of that free chicken
dog so you want any free chick going go
to waste if you don't give it to me my
local comini they look miserable I don't
blame them CU oh they do it's I it is a
rough comini it does not look good at at
our old place uh up in you know up north
like there was the comy worker near our
house like lateer at night who just used
to to give me free chicken every time I
walked in he was just like we got some
we're going to throw it out do you want
I'm like sure hey are you the anime man
do you want a free chicken he recognized
you right yeah he recognized me and then
he was like oh you want some free
chicken I'm like okay I wish it was that
easy Joey I
know I wish I could be that famous to be
reced wish it was I wish it was Lawson
then I'd be interested in the free
chicken yeah family Mar chicken get that
[__] out of here yeah every everyone I
know everyone I know in uh in Tokyo they
just agree that fing m is the worst
there's a lot of arguments over 7-Eleven
and Lawson's but I think family m is the
worst well family M chicken for sure is
the worst like that is all their food
selection is [__] yeah you know 7-Eleven
the smoothies those are [__] Godlike
you can buy these smoothies in 7-Eleven
where it's like you get out of the
freezer it's just I saw a Tik
Tok I saw a Tik Tok I went to the
[__] store and I no no no I saw I saw
a Tik Tok where some guy was like this
is why Japan is living in 20 make a
[__] smoothie yeah this right yeah I
I saw I saw a Tik Tok where it was like
this is why Japan is living in the
future have
blenders because they have blenders get
the [__] pink one it's strawberry soy
and it's [__] Godlike it's got like
like a bunch of protein too it's 100
calories it tastes so [__] good get
it it's so good it is very convenient I
do loveo cuz like I you know sometimes I
want to drink but I don't want a coffee
and I just want something that's
refreshing that's nice and it's and it's
200 yen in the summer as well especially
cuz it comes out of the freezer as well
like yeah it's so nice they they're
constantly upping it like I genuinely
think every time I've left Japan now I'm
like man I don't think I can ever leave
Japan like I don't think I I can live
anywhere else yeah Comin are too strong
here yeah it made me I may I realized
this even going to Korea and I'm like
Comin game we compared to Japan I don't
know if I could uh I don't know if I
could live here and their comines
compared to like Tesco or something is
still [__] Gods tier but uh Japan
comines are just on another level a lot
of people always like when you're going
to move to LA Conor or something I'm
like no I I I literally just can't leave
Japan it's it's too good I'm too I I
like my I like my life too much day by
day it's UB for everything anyway Conor
yeah that's great yeah but I love
walking around it's it's great because
we can always tell I can I can now tell
how often Connor uses Uber cuz we have a
company card okay I fixed it now I fix
we have a company card and Connor did
not realize that he was using his
personal Uber orders on the company
what the [__] I never agreed to this
yeah well I I reimbursed you guys I
reimbursed you guys all right I'm a man
of my word okay so I giving this man
free meals for no no I reimbursed it I
gave the money
back I remember I was just chilling and
I get this notification being like you
uh your your card has uh been charged
for Uber and I was like wait uh none of
the boys are here I'm at home why why
who's using Uber right now and I log on
to the app that we all have and I scroll
down and there's like five Uber e orders
all marked to Connor 5 days in a row and
I'm like Connor what the [__] M our
bosses suck all right I love going out
he says no I I love walking around but
in terms of like meals I feel like I
still don't often like I won't just stop
at a place and eat normally I I I've
been walking a lot around lately even if
it's like an hour and a half walk I'm
like [__] it I walk why not yeah because
I want I love doing this now I just walk
to a place and when I'm passing places
that look cool I'll look them up on
Google and I'll see the pictures of the
food and how it is and I'll be like okay
I'm saving this I'm going here and then
he goes home in order super yeah I don't
want to eat out all the time right
because I want to most like so so you
eat out in yeah well it's salad most of
the time just [__] ordering a salad
it's boring uh you know it sucks it's a
shame I felt bad cuz I messaged Conor
when he was like live on stream or some
[__] and I was like yo can you uh I
think you've been charging the company
card for your for your all orders I got
the notification too I was like [__]
like yeah I know continues to
play there nothing I could do in the
moment you know the burrito was
coming it's all good it was a good
burrito though oh so it's the end of the
year you guys are ready for next year no
I've not heard a single person say
they're excited for
2024 just what what is there to be
excited about nothing I mean people were
optimistic uh I feel like Co removed
optimism for like hoping for the next
New Year to we're still recovering from
Co I think we are people are just the
world is not well adjusted still it's
not the same man it's not the same I
mean I feel like before people were more
optimistic they like yeah this year is
going to be my year and I don't know if
the world just got a lot more
pessimistic but uh I think the world has
got more pessimistic I especially after
you know so many of them had to
experience the horrors of Co right like
you know it'd be it's pretty like it's
pretty difficult to just tell someone
like you know you were locked in the
house for like three and a half years
but yeah it gets better don't worry it's
like you know hard to believe for some
people there's there there's two sides
of this where it's like all right if I'm
like if I was in school right during
covid I I get like two [__] years of
schooling maybe three of like just
schooling that is crap because I'm on
Zoom yeah right and then uh maybe I I
graduate or something especially if
you're around graduating time this is
Dreadful you go to the workforce like oh
by the way uh also your your country
everyone's getting old and you're going
to have to pay like double the tax your
elders paid you can't afford a house rip
it's like okay well [__] I guess what is
there to be excited for like I'm I'm
literally told that it is going to get
worse for me um but on the other hand
I'm like GTA 6 though yeah on the other
hand on the other hand GTA 6 yo GTA 6
though Persona 3 reload though [__]
Hy games hyp TV shows but then but then
I can't even get excited about hyp TV
shows or games because there was the
rider strike this year and actor strike
so that in like four years we're going
to get like [__] Lost season 4 and
Prison Break season 3 all over again
where every TV gets suffered now because
of the rider strike um so it's like all
right well great so [__] not that's
like not a lot to look forward to yeah
um AI is getting worse um it's a pretty
good time to be miserable if you were
betting on that I don't I feel okay what
do you think do you think there's going
to be a new tech fad next year I swear
to God every year now there is some new
tech fad AI is going to be like the next
big thing for the next like 10 years AI
is going to likee like prevail the it's
only going to get bigger and more
prevalent I totally agree with that but
maybe like
AR potentially because like the year
before we had [__] nfts
and bring them back that's my child yeah
like the year like the year before last
uh was it like I think it was last year
we had nfts and then before that it was
like Bitcoin uh then this year it was
like AI where people like losing that
[__] I swear to God like Tech Bros find
a thing a new thing to get excited about
every single I swear it's going to be
like that AR [__] you know after they
after Apple announced like those goggle
things like Tech Bros are going to be
all over that and you're going to be
like augmented reality is is the future
it's going to up our productivity it's
going to make everything so you know
safe for people blah blah blah and it's
like it's just going to be another F
like it always has unless I'm wrong and
this ages like milk but you know so far
the track record hasn't been great you
know people saying the same thing about
nfts 3 years ago and look what happened
to that yeah I mean the some of these
ideas sound very exciting you know I AI
I think we just need to figure out what
the line is between what's ethical and
what's not because people are going to
use it either way shape or form right
totally uh AR is the Apple Vision coming
out next year uh [__] when's it coming
out I think it's next year right or it's
2025 yeah when's it when's it coming
out but that's just porn for rich people
you know what I
mean early early 2024
yeah holy [__] I'm paying 4K to watch
porn I'm just not like that's that's
disgusting well you can you can do that
with uh any [__] VR system right you
do you can do that with an Oculus too if
does need to be the I tried watching
porn and VR one time cuz I was
interested to see how it was and I was
this is a horrible experience yeah this
is like motion sickness meets [__] it
doesn't even look good either no it does
it's all like warped and [__] like all
right I I I got like I got to ask at
which point does your mate come like
come home with like a purchase he does
that but also comes on with the purchase
and you're like all right we got to have
a talk we got to have an intervention
here because I saw I saw this tweet the
other day I'm going to see if I can find
but it was like it was this [__] own
hle that was basically uh that was
basically strapped on to a
jackhammer that's almost an auto Jacker
yeah so it was like an auto Jacker that
would just that that you would hold like
you were you they would hold
and you would it would [__]
jackhammer your dick off right and then
the Tweet was woman be careful or
something wom like woman be aware and
and at that point you at that point you
got to be like all right how far is too
far man how far how far do we have to go
before you have to have an intervention
you know what I uh I respect that I I do
this series where I review my viewers
rooms right and somebody had like uh a
bust it was like a torso that had a hole
at the bottom so it was like a it was
like a a torso of a woman that you could
you know do things to yeah and I think
that's too far gone like like well like
like here to here uh like here to like
leg area oh okay so the hole was in the
normal spot yeah yeah yeah yeah oh okay
okay so like you it was like you would
you were you know you were doing it but
I I felt like that's too far but it had
no head no arms no no no but I F like
that like if you are having sex with
that you are there's something wrong I
don't see what's the problem with just
using your hand if I'm being honest you
know but I feel like if you're buying
that [__] around it I'm like come on man
like this we should be investing
elsewhere all right I found the Tweet
the Tweet is I will forget you exist and
this no way I've seen that before you've
seen that before I've seen this tweet
that's actually and there's a phone
holder at the top and there's a phone
holder at the top so you got to J there
is definitely no way I can show this on
uh YouTube but yeah you can show that
you can show can I show this I think you
can show that so good all
right I guess I'll send you the link gu
uh for you to show mood on it like I
think like theoretically it's like yeah
that stuff could work but it's like when
you buy [__] like that or make that
you're like resigning yourself to you're
like well I'm just this is going to be
my life yeah pretty much I I feel I me
you at that point you will forget that
girls exist because uh girls can't
provide that kind of same convenience as
this phone holder Jackhammer that Jacks
you off at the same time you know that's
what the take Bros are going to be on
next year that's that's the new that's
the new thing we're going to be scared
of it's just like the apocalypse is
happening birth rate is going down
humanity is going extinct and there's
nothing we can do about it cuz
everyone's busy going to be like one
uping each other being like mine's got a
six piston Well mine's got an eight
piston she got a V8 in it
[Laughter]
V8 I'm try this cheat mine's got a 4080
inside of
it oh my God yeah uh I don't know
honestly like I feel like the past years
when like I guess the the term Tech bro
especially was kind of starting to come
into relevance uh in the mainstream I
guess uh like I had no clue every single
year it was it was kind of a game for me
to be like what is it going to be this
time and uh let's just say I didn't see
nfts coming I didn't see nfts coming no
I don't know I called the them making
one piece remake I told I I said it on
the podcast like they're going to remake
one
piece when they were done with one piece
I said when they were done though
they're not even done with it but I I
called they were going to remake it and
they did but they were F they jumped the
[__] gun they were like [__] it let's
do it now they got to capitalize on a
while it's hot right but yeah I think
jacking off to a jackhammer probably not
good for your mental even if even if
you're I think your mental is a bit far
you know like you should do that you if
you if you own a a [__] [__] doll
at home get rid of it get rid of it just
use your hand bro please for your own
sake yeah it's no different from
watching yes it is you bought a
human-sized [__] toy it is very
different no cuz even the Tanger video
that we did some of the Contraptions
that they like brought out for us uh
[__] ABS they're monetizing your
loneliness yeah yeah you are lonely and
they are taking advantage of you by
saying hey look what you need you know
cuz I see some of these Contraptions and
at that point it kind of just feels like
you're just hacking the mind to find the
most efficient way to jack off and uh
unfortunately uh if you've never been
you know if you've never had partner
before you know that you know sex isn't
the most efficient thing of all time you
know it it actually takes a lot of work
a lot of times it's a workout it's two
pumps for me
G I just have to walk in a
woman two p and done that's what they
call me look to my
eyes was that [__] Mana where he like
the guy with like the [__] touch I can't
remember the name of it oh yeah yeah
yeah uh [__] what was what was the name
of oh [__] it's my favorite Mana oh it's
such a good Mana I can't remember it
though uh golden not golden boy
uh that's something else Golden Touch I
don't know yeah but uh yeah humanity is
more and more [__] every year yeah I
can see why the older generation like
you know keeps repeating that yeah but
this has been like a phenomenon for for
um centuries where the previous
generation deem the coming generation to
be oh for sure but I feel like this time
they're on to something no no you feel
that cuz it's your every generation felt
like that Joey yeah there's literally
like newspaper articles of like the
early 1800s being like these these new
generations have no manners they can't
they can't function in they're walking
around showing ankle yeah and you know
they then the next Generation does the
same thing this is a Perpetual thing
where obviously the newer generation are
going to evolve you know and it's up to
us to evolve evolve you mean grow up no
evolve like what they what their tastes
are like
Pokemon like what
our dad wasn't jacking human evolving
jacking into a Tanger you know what I
mean that's a new that's a new
development Jack Hammer's hold this
that's a new generation they're evolving
but I will say yes you know definitely
every generation for the past couple of
centuries have been saying that about
the newer generations for sure but I
feel no you're falling into the Trap J
you feel like we're the different one
the next one really is [__] no but like
we were talking about like the the uh
you know lessening of optimism in the
newer generation right
like has that happened in previous
generations Maybe not maybe they have
but maybe not to the same extent as it
is now because we're running into I
actually feel like Millennials we
started that Trend te just kind of like
went with the depression Trend and we're
just like actually we can do it better
than you we ran so Jin could walk I'm
sure there was somebody in 1910 they
were like oh boy G in America I can't
wait to join the job market next year
boom great depression no jobs for you
everyone is starving four year three or
four years this [__] lasts for yeah I'm
sure they would probably think well we
had it [__] bad obviously but like
you know say for like say for like our
generation right like Millennials yeah
were we was it so much of a common uh
like uh idea between like people of Our
Generation I guess the newer generation
to be like as like doomy or sad about
our future compared to like this newer
generation well also we didn't have to
[__] kill each other you know you you
talked to the the older generation and
they went through [__] several World
there like several
Wars and like they they look at our
generation I'm like what the [__] do you
have war with clearly yeah clearly but
I'm talking about this newer generation
now right like the newest generation
like why is there suddenly so much of a
bigger shift I think what [__] uh I
think there's just a lot more shared
experience and also you know there was
definitely like houses were and stuff
like that house house rent and whatnot
was definitely Rising like 20 years ago
but obviously there wasn't as many
people talking about it online uh and
arguing about it also you have to bear
in mind that like like 20 30 years ago
it was kind of seems like a bad thing to
be like I can't afford this or like
might money nowadays it's like hey can
you also not afford rent this might I
can't afford R completely anecdotal
because I have no evidence to back this
up but this yeah this is all pure
speculation like like for me but uh I
think just just existing has never been
harder yeah just just just the act of
existing you know um you know maybe that
you know that you had some bad times
like the Great Depression obviously bad
times as we big S as we like to call it
the big sagge okay we should have the
Great Depression no we shouldn't have
that what should call it something
better not the Great Depression the big
sag yeah we we call it s if we have
another one we should the big S we'll
call the big S the big sagge of the 23r
yeah it's a 100 years
cycle when did they coin the term Great
Depression was it during the time or it
was it was happening in the 30s right
well this this is like a good question
of like did they call it um because it
was called the Great War World War one
and they asked when did they start
referring to it as World War I yeah and
it was until I think a lot long after
wari was probably not until World War II
right but I think it was sometime after
as well it wasn't immediately after they
weren't like I remember one this is the
sequel yeah I think it was there was a
good video about it I can't remember
what it's was called right uh but I mean
that doesn't [__] matter it's stupid
stupid figuring out when [__] was named
but like you I wonder well what what are
they going to name it's based on a book
called The Great Depression by Hoover oh
okay what are they going to name Co
times reckon when historians look back
and think Co pandemic I don't know is
this this this isn't the first pandemic
we've been through though right this is
this is the first Global pandemic in a
very long time I mean there was the
Black Death as well but that was only in
Europe only that only wiped out like a
third of a third of humanity also if you
remember that like this is the first
pandemic that's been available uh that's
very easily spread in the modern travel
era where people can just get like I can
get to I can be in Australia tomorrow
yeah it was kind of difficult to travel
in the 1300 you back then they like I
think in like uh in I think one of the
wars there was like uh uh there was a
kind of influenza that was that was
wreaking havoc yeah um and but that was
localized to Europe at that time right
cuz people like flying all over the
[__] place spreading it to their like
whoever and everyone um so yeah it's I
mean it's interesting I think it's it's
weird cuz like I obviously we we're in
very good Financial places but I still
feel like holy [__] like I buying a
house is still a hard thing to do oh
which is like crazy I'm like oh my god
when I look back at brochures they're
like yeah we'll ship you a house and you
build it for for $10,000 I'm like what
it's a giant Lego set yeah they used to
sell made to order houses they would
just send you the parts and you build it
this is the thing America I that was
crazy that's so cool we can't do that
now that's insane uh yeah those was made
to order houses that uh you could they
were in America uh that's prefab but I
think that's all pra come up you could
literally get sent and they would send
you all the things in like crates and
you would presumably just building oh my
God this is like Ikea nightmare mode
this is your final this is your final
boss after this is what the Lego
training up with the Legos and this is
the final boss mail order house it's
beautiful that's a yeah that's a nice
house holy [__] yeah obviously even even
with inflation it was still way more
affordable than houses nowadays yeah um
it's crazy though but that's back when
everyone just I guess somehow knew how
to build a house yeah I oh yeah it was
$2,000 in uh 19 something which even
with inflation wouldn't come close to 19
1960 16 what's what's $2,000 in 1916 in
today's money could you have a look 2
million just type it in there there's
like calculators to tell you no I've
I've been recommended more and more
videos of just people living on the road
in [__] Vans and Caravans and [__]
that feels like like a a kind of
subconscious like struggle answer to
this world we liveing where it's like I
can't [__] pay $31,000 that's nothing
yeah holy [__] what the [__] cars are
more expensive than yeah I mean I could
you guys ever do that like just pack up
okay number one I find this concept
really interesting because I don't know
how many other countries you can get
away with doing this aside from America
because it's funny cuz I've actually uh
met people that have done that life uh
when I went back to Wisconsin this year
uh Sydney's like extended Friendship
Circle had like some new people join and
they had had a year or maybe two years
just literally they sold everything they
owned put everything into a van and just
traveled the road and just lived on the
road for two years and after two years
they just hit Wisconsin and were like I
think we've had enough of traveling
let's just uh just get an apartment
that's badass it's [__] badass but
holy [__] it made me realize how op
America is because I couldn't like
imagine like traveling imagine England
in a week yeah imagine doing that in
England or some [__] cuz they were like
yeah we started off in like West Coast
went up north went all the way to Alaska
for like a bit like drove back down and
I'm like yo you drive through Canada as
well yeah I'm like yo that sounds
[__] badass I mean we we kind of in a
sense did like a a a light version of
that on the US tour right like we were
we were in that bus for 50 days I I
don't think I can do and considering
that I enjoyed the tour the most I could
probably do
it I like I need to be stationary to do
anything like I like having a Zone my
little safe save point where I'm like
this is where I like subconsciously this
is where I clock in and out of life
right I need that but wouldn't you say
that that's the little personal van
personal vehicle that you have no cuz
you're never truly stationary right
you're always subject to someone else's
rules right if you park in this place
all right what how can you park here or
what can you do yeah if you put in the
middle of [__] desert okay but then
what if something goes wrong you know
what if you pop a tire in the middle of
the [__] desert for some reason
you're driving there I know there's
there's so many factors that's that's
like that's like city boy mentality all
the way cuz I actually I absolutely
agree I would be terrified I care too
much about everything that could go
wrong and I think you have you cannot
care about [__] going wrong if you want
to live that lifestyle you need to like
almost disregard oh how am I going to a
shower how am I going to do laundry like
I'm sure and they work it out right
because they're they're like but to me I
wouldn't even want to embark on this
unless I figured it all out and I
wouldn't even want to go on it unless I
figured out the route which is like
psychotic and I I just can't do it like
I just to me it wouldn't yeah so you
don't have a manly urge to drop
everything and just build a cabin in the
woods and just [__] survive on
survive on the Wilderness me I do that
the first thing I'm doing when I retire
bro well I like too many of the modern
comforts you know I'm I like a lot of
them that's how it is and I think
there's nothing wrong with
that [__] love a good meal and I love
a good coffee that's what matters ain't
nothing wrong with that dog that's
that's nothing wrong with that as well
but the more I go the more the more I
grow older the more I'm like yeah that
manly urge is real I don't know if it's
an actual manly urge but it's just an
urge I just really want to do it is that
more so an urge that you want to have
that life or that you are you are not
content with what is currently happening
in life and the the cycle you're in no I
think it's more so like I am I'm very
much you know I the urge is in the
future for me like I I'm completely
content with my life now and I'm very
happy with where I am now in my life and
I would like to continue it for as long
as possible but I know there's going to
be a point where I'm probably going to
hit a wall where I'm just like I need
some change in my life Chee mhm you know
or cheese you know oh Chee you know I
need I need some change in my life I
need some kind of radical change in my
life whether it be for my mental health
or whether it be just like if I'm still
doing a creative job you know it's
always a nice change Pace to like switch
your environment it's just nice I I know
I like the thought of just removing all
complexities from your life I mean I
guess I've done it once before uh but
that was like a very very extreme
version of just removing all external
complexities this is kind of like a
lighter version where you're kind of
just doing your own thing you're living
to uh you're just living man you're just
you're just living out there I'd be
happy like camping for a month that'd be
fun yeah the yeah yeah the joy I get
from making a fire and cooking a meal on
that fire yeah but think about it if you
lived in a van you could do that
anywhere you want whenever you want yeah
you're as long as you're not in
someone's backyard you can do that
wherever you want bro that America has
so much land man [__] yeah yeah but I
I'm like okay I'd rather just travel
around it and I don't know when I see
these van videos sometimes it makes me
depressed why cuz I I look at it and I'm
like wow you don't have an espresso
machine you p
you can you can install one in the van
that's the first thing a lot better than
others but sometimes someone will show
their van and it's like it just looks
really sad it also looks lonely okay
there are there are different levels
like I've also I've also seen [__]
Justin Bieber's T us that's see that's
where I'm like all right let's do this
let's do this man like can you can you
show Justin Bieber custom tour us this
is where I can do the van lock all this
is like that's not a van at that point
but I saw this one where this woman had
to like she was like I'm going to shower
now what the [__] Jesus Christ I I think
I can do the that's a hotel room I can
do that's a moving hotel room yeah I can
do the life oh if it was this I could
leave in there for the rest of my life
like there there's like so many levels
to it but it's basically what you
comfortable with because I like it I've
been recommended every level which
includes just guys who are living out of
their cars in New York living out living
out of their Mini Coopers no no no like
literally just living out of their cars
and he's like here's my apartment tour
and like I think my favorite comment is
just like [__] will be homeless
in New York but be like but the food is
really good
though that's true that's
true [__] will live literally
live out with shoe box pay 3K off the
most about New York when they [__]
tell me about their water I don't give a
[__] about your water and why it makes
bread taste better stop [__] telling
no one cares about your [__] water I
haven't heard about this New York water
thing oh my God if you talk to a New
Yorker they don't shut the [__] up about
it you're like I New Yorkers like we got
the best bread in all in America I'm
like it's not that good it's it's you
think it's better than it is like no no
our water is scientifically proved it's
the best water in all this and it's like
no I don't think so I disagree uh like
scientifically and I'm like I I I have
you been to Europe no but New York we
got the it's like shut up shut up shut
up shut
up damn did you notice this when we were
in New York [__] will never shot up
by that damn water and white makes bread
taste perfect never I never heard a yor
is talking about their water maybe I
lucky I I find it Charming I summoned
them in the comments no I I find I found
it Charming at first c yeah until you
literally can't tell them their bread is
not the best in the world they won they
won't they won't take it KH it's like
it's like getting yongo J bro it's
Charming at first and then it gets
[__] annoying you can't tell them
their Bread's not the best in the world
they they lose it they like they like
self-destruct rage we got the delies
though I know you you you go to a lot of
parts in America and you know some parts
are more like the others New York is one
of like one of the cities that I think
has its own kind of culture which I
think abely which I think it has a real
unique identity to it which is more than
I can say for a lot of cities uh In
America which is something I really
really respect about New York and New
Yorkers as well which is like an
identity you know I kind of like dig
that okay but like do you think that the
whole van life stuff cuz I there's so
many van life influences which uh my
brother's actually been inspired by oh
yeah he's got his own van oh [__] um and
he travels around it's fine it's nice
it's cozy dude my dream car is a Combi
van oh really yeah Volkswagen Callie ban
I really want one what I I don't know
what he has but it's it's good uh and um
I for him it was like okay well he'll
work on it a bunch but my my dad helped
mostly yeah but uh if I tell him that
he'll get annoyed but true um but like
for him it's like okay that's more of a
like a okay we live in this place we
have a good time then we maybe we do
like weekl long trips in this thing and
for that I was like that sounds like a
really healthy way but when I'm like
you're living out of it and then I see
some of these videos and I'm like is
this just like I don't know does it feel
like the last option CU it's like I
don't know what to do like I'm it to me
some of these some of these videos just
felt really sad when I watched them why
sad cuz they just look lonely they look
so lonely maybe maybe they like that
maybe they like that like solidarity in
this one video this one person they even
said that they were like yeah the
hardest thing about doing van life is uh
you know it's the fact that you don't
really get to talk with people or meet
with people cuz you're always in a new
place but look I installed a new shower
in my van and I was like whoa whoa whoa
but it's glossed over the most important
pressing factor ofbe maybe it's my
perspective but I always looked at these
like van people who live out of these
Vans and go traveling the country or the
world or whatever I've always seen it as
like well isn't the point to like living
in a van so that you can go see these
new places and meet these new people
like isn't the social aspect really tied
in with your lifestyle yeah but I guess
some people maybe they didn't think
about because a lot a lot of people
never think about social life or being
social it's always an afterthought for
everyone right maybe they jumped on the
van life they were like I'm just GNA
[__] ran everyone yeah maybe maybe
they We Wrong how do I maintain
friendships here how do I have like a
existence because ultimately we're all
human and we all need to have
friendships yeah social creatures even
the most like even the biggest
introverts will crave social interaction
every now and again because that is just
how we survived and how we've evolved
and how our brains are on the meat I
couldn't couldn't break it apart you
know it's it's it's uh and that to me
would be the the biggest thing that I'd
miss is like how the [__] do I have any
meaningful conversations or connections
with people while I'm in a van yeah I'm
not the same place but that's like why
wouldn't I just stay
home yeah but you can travel the world
and also also sometimes you know I know
I know it's not a big deal but I I feel
bad when some of the van people I saw
this dude who had like three pets and I
was like I'm like maybe you shouldn't
have three pets in a van I'm like I know
I know you can stet the pets get to
uhu get to go crazy but I'm like man I
feel bad when it depends what kind of
pet as well yeah yeah I don't know yeah
if it's a [__] if it's three dogs
then I don't think there's anything
wrong with that yeah yeah yeah but I
guess it also depends on type of dog as
well I guess all right going back to the
going back to the generational thing all
I had a thought do you think every
generation is destined to get more horny
than the previous
generation do you know what made me
think this so I was like the internet
not just not just the internet but uh so
I had had I was uh I was like on a trip
and we had like a night where we were
watching like the biggest hits of the
2000s whatever and a video of tattoo
came on do you remember tattoo yeah [__]
yeah all the things she said yeah
[__] love that song do you remember
how much of a [__] storm it caused
because it just had two like girls in
Rain like making out and everyone's like
oh this is the [__] holy [__] and
parents were like no this we can't show
this to the children it's too sexualized
it's too edgy I don't remember this at
all it they were huge in Japan yeah it
might have been just before like just
before two Russian girls right yeah yeah
two Russian girls like it it was it was
massive for me when uh when when it came
out um and I it came on and then I
remember looking at it I'm like [__]
this is tame as [__] man this is well
even even like a little bit after that
right like when we were growing up like
I remember being you know [__] I
don't remember remember how old I was it
was definitely before I hit puberty and
you watch [__] Christina Aguilera
music videos and you're just like God
damn like I don't want my parents
walking in on me on this like all right
then I think there's a there's a very
important question to ask to to help
answer your question which is do you
think people are born with weird Kinks
or is it something that you're
introduced to and you're like oh I think
yeah I think it's all about introduction
right you think so do you think that
like if you were a feet person yeah
right oh I guess feet that doesn't count
CU You' always see feet but if you were
in a s weird like um I know what's a
weird fetish armpits no you'd see that a
lot you see armpits like you wouldn't
see natur like uh you know who's into
armpits
now no but like I like you see yeah
armpits are oh yeah I was going to do
this you could easily if you were like a
medieval peasant
you were in like
800 you could easily see a woman open up
a thing actually hold on a second I
[__] [__] with the armpits but like
you would never be introduced to like
cucking right unless maybe it happened
to you and you were like hold on but
like the normal person would no man
you're in Japan yeah the normal person
would not be introduced like NTR right
sure sure most most people okay so I'm
sure there's some situation okay yeah
most people wouldn't be introduced to
NTR right yeah so the theory is like
would would you have been born
being like I am going to like ntrr at
some point or is it like I have to then
show you and then you're like huh I
don't even think it's about showing I
think it's just about like the the
number of stimuli that you are subject
to Growing Up all just kind of combined
together into like clicking to be like I
like this thing so then so then so like
okay cuz hypothetically think about it
if there was a person who was born right
and they spent their entire like first
18 20 years he comes out he comes out
with the mother's vagina he's like Mama
I am a cut
do you know what your first words were
[__] say say say say m
[__] no but okay like let's think about
this hypothetically right if there was a
child who was born right and for the
first in Japan impossible yeah not in
Japan let's say Europe uh you know they
were born and for the first let's say 20
years they were born in a room and they
spend their entire lifetime in a room
which has like little to no stimuli
right like nothing in their room like
you know bare minimum human interaction
that is deemed as normal like no access
to the internet anything that kind of
stuff do you think they'll be able to
develop finishes from
that I don't think they will have mental
capacity to
function so we answered your question I
think I think there is you might be born
with like maybe some brain chemicals
like leaning towards maybe taking in
certain stimuli that let so then we
answer G's question then cuz G say is
the next Generation no I think I just
think the current generation is exposed
to a lot more Concepts yeah and
especially with the internet hor is very
easily accessible now and you know back
in the day even like 20 years ago you
had to go to a [__] store and buy it
um and even if you opened up like
Playboy magazines like 10 20 years ago
you wouldn't you wouldn't see like the
weird [__] that you see now so I feel
like it was more of a joined like it was
more of a communal thing where you like
did you see the Playboy you know did you
see the X model who is the hottest
now it's like what are you and someone
like I like getting sh on you're like
okay okay that's and to you cuz you've
had no exposing shame you had no
exposure to that you're like that's
[__] disgusting why would you do that
for him it's like he's exposed and then
I think that's I think that's also as a
result of the fact that now like the
internet is we not ready for the
internet well that's the thing we been
[__] because people go on the internet
and now we're so over stimulated that
the stuff that we deemed is like [__]
up 20 years ago is just like normalized
now so people are just looking for the
next thing do you think by the time we
die there'll be studies like showing
that the internet was just like we just
[__] weren't ready for the internet
like it like I think there are probably
studies that are have already it's
probably already I think it would be
more helpful when it's like we're all
dead said and done you know what I mean
when it's you know when they can really
sit back and look ah the whole life okay
let's have a look Ser here what happened
when the internet happened to so how did
it come to him liking NTR find out let's
dissect this brain I'm curious I mean I
don't even think NTR like I I saw like I
saw another tweet where it was just this
fetish of this person I don't I can't I
don't know if it was a guy or a girl
just in like full latex just getting
vacuumed to uh have you seen
that and I see that and I'm just like he
like euphoric how do you even like where
does this even come from like bro that
has to start with a porn addiction right
because here see like outfits and
they're like oh that's [__] hot yeah
here here's the thing like some things I
can like I have a theory that you know
most fetches come from maybe how we were
raised something to do with like what we
experienc most of the time I I have a I
have a theory that we were probably like
forbidden to like this kind of stuff or
we were told this thing is bad so like
mentally we we know this thing is bad
and that's why it P so well yeah that's
true it's a it's a the ultimate taboo
yeah yeah right I think for some people
breaking taboos is inherently attractive
yeah yeah exactly exactly so I I think
that's where a lot of fetishes start you
know um being vacuumed in a latex suit
I'm like how many you're missing the
steps how how many l i i can connect the
taboo dots I can't connect the vacuum
suck dot right Al I imagine I don't even
know if that's taboo in the day the only
people who could afford to indulge in
[__] up Kinks were like ultra wealthy
like landlords they were like well my
thing is that I love people being mimed
or something while you know or I love
people being branded that's my king
right you know and so back then it was
you know it's probably unlimited to like
people who had money I think think I
think po I think like peasants were like
well [__] I'm just trying to get by I'm
just trying to get some food you
fetishes are privileges I think it is
they are fetishes just okay just just
think about the latex Su how much is a
latex Su yeah think about that for a
times you able to hook that up get get
to a need to like probably 3D print you
need you need to either learn to learn
like to 3D print a device to be able to
vacuum yourself or someone has gone out
and designed that for you which you must
have paid a premium [__] price buy
buying a [__] doll buying a doll that
you can [__] is expensive a privil and
God forbid we already know how much
furries like spend on furry suit they
[__] funding the economy by
themselves I hate how much this makes
sense I you know I can see why this
generation feels like they're doomed
when we hear this kind of [__] it's just
like wine you know wine is a is a very
expensive hobby as is jacking off
sometimes when when Society has gone
down and everyone is homeless it'll be
the furries having the last laugh
because they'll be the last group of
people with money I swear to God they
have all the money
they we can make it through the harsh
winter in our suit
you know fur fur for the most part
yeah they sleeping good when we have the
Great Depression part two all we're
going to see on the streets are people
in fursuits man cuz that's that's the
only people with money left in the world
that's all I'm saying man every furry I
met they've been pretty chill as well
yeah they've they've been very chill Met
has been like the chillest dudes they've
been very chill and uh they have also uh
normally been uh very financially well
off as well to afford the hobby that
they do they are they prop up the artist
sphere online it's a Well documented F
on Jesus Christ maybe maybe like fet I
feel like with the overexposure of the
internet and with the overexposure of
new things I feel like this [__]
latex suit there must be why are you so
obsessed with this latex suit G I just
because it sounds absurd do you want a
latex shoot for your birthday no I'm
just I just want to know you say yes
we're ending the podcast
I really I'm I'll help him I want to see
where it goes I'm just genuinely curious
what the steps are you know like like
genuinely well it's like that it's like
that famous video of the guy like who
bought like the full latex like dog suit
right and like and like and like acts
like a dog he like sleeps in a giant
yeah yeah yeah he's like a British guy I
think okay first of all I take offense
to that probably English first of all
okay okay my bad my bad uh wasn't that
guy in Japan that wanted to be a dog so
he spent I mean that's the that's the
least weird thing in Japan when it comes
to fetishes bro there was a dude who
married a h Miku [__] body pillar he
the DS as well feel like man like it's
cool that we're like open to cool things
like that but also at the same time you
shouldn't you shouldn't do that you just
straight up should not marry a DS yeah
um I I just think that that's a bad idea
we shouldn't be congratulating at all
yeah we shouldn't be rewarding Behavior
like that ultimately like I think it's
funny and like it's it's makes a very
good BuzzFeed article but that's about
it I mean I would prefer that you just
be asexual at that point you know cuz I
can I can kind of vibe with that I can I
can understand that um if you know you
know some people are just wired that way
uh if you are falling in love with a DS
I see that as something that you're
replacing an animate object a asexuality
is not doesn't mean the lack of romance
there so they still you know you start
be in a relationship uh you just might
not be physical Ed it so you know
whereas a DS you can't have either so
you just well I I see the DS as you
replacing something that you couldn't
get you know because it's tough right
because I guess how do you how do you
like if if if Joey comes to us tomorrow
and he's like guys I've fall in love
with my PSP V first of all great choice
to console to fall in love with second
of all also it's called a PS uh yeah it
is it's great yeah they amazing games on
it what are you like what what all those
amazing exclus were only on the PS well
90% of them never came out of Japan so
outside of Japan yeah outside cuz it was
a great console uh and Japan [__]
used it until like five years ago yeah
uh anyway it was the only country pspv
to sorry PSV to sorry to insult you and
your wife um I think I'd be like hey
Jerry what's going on like I wouldn't be
like dude that's cool I'm Progressive
I'm like no Jerry what's wrong like
there's something's gone wrong here yeah
and I and you know I think that's fair
we shouldn't be like yeah yes to
everything I think be like wait hold on
a second no don't this is a terrible
what has happened can you please think
about this can you talk to us tell me
what happened yeah um and if you don't
have that in your life then there's
another there's an even bigger problem
going on where were that dude's friends
when he married the DS genuine question
what friends yeah exactly who stopped
him who was like hey man I really think
this might not be a good idea do you
think his friends would have stopped him
when his parents were like first of all
first of all he loves this is presuming
that this was a legit thing and not like
some kind of publicity St publicity St
whatever but if it is a real apparently
it was legit okay well that's like he
went to the ward office and signed
papers and [__] oh my God and they they
did it yeah that's crazy they would let
a man marry a DS but not let two gays
marry that's that I mean that's all I'm
going to say that's crazy you can marry
DS that's why society's doomed
brother yeah
um I don't have anything to add on to
that man that's just a [__] bombshell
and I'm just like like did he really get
no there's no way he legally got married
there must been a ceremony there's no
way he legally I don't believe get on it
guy
guy guy guy behind computer guy look it
up Japanese man has married a character
in a popular video game taking her and
his handheld game console on an overseas
honeymoon there's no way it's a real
marriage think it must just be publish
four picture why does it look like young
PRD in that one
picture oh my
God the on the one on the fourth one you
know
a pro fake character in one of his
[Laughter]
skits uh yeah where is the news on that
but at which point are you just like you
know the guy married the body pillar at
which point are you just like you know
what I'm happy that you're happy you
know like where did you draw the line of
that I guess I draw the line when it's a
Nintendo console you know I think that's
where I draw the line honestly did uh
whoever owns hats Miku have to sign off
on the marriage
well I think in the case of the DS one
it wasn't Hudson and Miku it was a oh
yeah it was it was a character from a
dating simulator Called Love plus yeah
because it was one of the first dating
Sims that was kind of AR technology cuz
with the DS I think it had like a GPS or
something and you could L you could
literally take this virtu the camera on
it right yeah yeah you could literally
take this virtual girl on Virtual dates
and it was one of the very first of its
kind maybe I don't know why I'm so
adverse to the idea I'm honestly like I
reckon if if I was the developer of that
like visual novel I would have
absolutely been on border with it
because that is amazing promotion for
the game I'm so torn cuz at the same
time what if the guy's happy like if
he's genuinely happy what can I like is
there a reason why he shouldn't do it
I'm so torn CU I'm like you shouldn't be
allowed to do this no I don't so if he's
really happy and that made him happy who
am I to rob that man of his happiness
yeah but there's other ways to be happy
you know yeah that are not like
impossible to obtain but then I think
about like some friends I have where
they well I think they're happy and they
drink but I'm like I think they could be
happy other ways happens to be that
drinking is what makes them happy right
now you know what I mean so I'm really
Tor like you are entitled to your
happiness yeah sure oh yeah of course
but is that happiness like to a self-
determent almost like is that you know I
don't know I don't know yeah I mean he
looks [__] happy in that picture he
looks very happy that's not love that
was 2020 as well that's years lat I
remember I remember this advert he must
be just going along with it no no shot
bro I don't believe it I I don't believe
it's real I don't I don't no way did you
see that Tinder added a Pay to Win
function now $500 a month $500 yeah if
you are paying $500 for Tinder you all
have actually I think I'd rather get you
like
marry this is like the different DS now
if I if I knew if I knew my friend was
paying for that Tinder premium I'm
buying him a DS I'll be like yo bro I
got this new girl I swear down and you
know that proves to a fact that uh does
not give a single [__] not not they have
but they always they always use this
veil of like we actually you know we
have had success stories I fully believe
Tinder has some success stories but you
know some oh no no I I have a friend
from high school who
married there's definitely people you
know and and I they use those stories as
like look we we are we are offering a
valuable function and at times they do
but then they pull [__] like this and
other stuff that they've done in the
past where they've made it so that like
you straight up just if you are an
undesirable man you won't be matched
with anyone yeah uh because your score
is your your inapp score is too low
that's so [__] up um and then offering
$500 to me is is say is symbolizing and
willing to take advantage of people who
are so desperate to meet someone else
that's what it is it's not like this guy
who's found of the S he's happy you are
actively taking advantage of of the
loneliest people with money to burn
because listen any single person on
Earth that you meet up with you tell
them you spent $500 on Tinder
immediately unattractive there's no one
on earth who's going to find that
attractive totally I bet those those
dudes are the type of dudes that will
ask to split the bill anyway but um the
point being is that you're just wasting
$500 a month to be lonely it's it's it's
it's such a [__] awful idea uh and
I'm it's [__] embarrassing I hope
that they don't actually do it I hope
it's just a publicity St yeah please
don't do it like this I don't the sad
thing is I don't think it is a publicity
stun I think they just want to make
money it's I think to for them it's a
legit business move which I think
unfortunately is going to work OB
they've obviously done research before
launching something like this they've
obviously identified a market for this
and you know a lot of people are
clowning on it but I think I think those
people who are clowning on it were never
going to be part of that target audience
anyway you know I think there is that is
a very specific target audience and I
think honestly uh there is a market for
it it's just now it's just out there in
the open there's always been a market
for it for yeah people who want to find
Partners who have a lot of money and
partners who are willing to pay for that
when I first moved to Japan I I I had uh
Tinder premium which allowed you to like
unlimited because I was just lonely I
just wanted to meet someone yeah oh yeah
because there was a limit to how many
you there's a limit right and you know
to me I was just like I just want to
have the highest chance possible of
being able to [__] meet up with
someone right yeah um and then I
realized they what they do is they
constantly dangle ahead of you they're
like wait but like
if you had this feature pretty sure we
can get you
someone you are not a high enough rank
yeah but I was never going to do it I
was like I'm already paying [__] five
[__] dollars a month [__] you give
you any more [__] money um and they
would just dangle these things in front
of you and they would add these
superficial features that just did not
help just straight up just did not help
um and you know T Tinder has proven if
you are of a certain
desirability uh you will just not have
success on Tinder it just you're you've
you know the the app is figured out that
no one wants to [__] date you bed on
your profile for whatever reason and and
no amount of money is going to solve
that problem so you you know it's just
cruel it's so cruel it's yeah they're
taking money to give you the illusion
that you still have a chance yeah it's
you know it's just [__] up and not to
mention all the fake profiles and stuff
like that and I very quickly gave up on
Tinder um in panks I was like [__] this
is stupid what you guys think of the
whole like pickup artists have you have
you heard of like the whole pickup
artist
there's a community for that lot
YouTubers who are pickup artists there's
also a guy who's married who's a pickup
artist and there's one video where he
made his wife watch his videos with him
are you serious it was the most it was
the most painful video I've ever seen in
my life what's wrong with people um yeah
it was uh I think Charlie did a video
about it and it was a horrible to watch
Wait so so explain this like pickup
artist Community to me so it's a
community of men basically of men uh
it's
it's kind of an offshoot of let's say
the guru community that I think there's
that's like you know they have like you
have like the financial Bros you have
the way a woman yeah now you have like
the now you have like the pick like now
you have like the pickup artist
Community which is kind of that same
kind of Guru structure but for lonely
guys who want to learn how do they just
like teach you pickup lines they no they
teach you how to be aggressive towards
women normally
these dudes are just aggressive they're
just and you know I if you cast women
love that if you cast the net out wide
enough you're bound to have some success
right that's that's I I want to see a
pickup artist in that community that
just like teaches dudes like just
terrible pickup lines that just never
work all of them all of them do that a
lot of are you from Tennessee you're the
only 10 I see a lot of them are like hey
buy my course you know yeah a lot of
them are just like here uh let me show
you how to pick up 10 girls and get a
get a number 90% success rate or some
[__] like that I call this the infinite
[__] glitch a lot of these guys who are
making these videos are conventionally
very attractive so You' already the the
easiest thing that you can do to
increase your chance of Landing a date
or a pickup is be [__] hot which most
of us aren you know that's not how it
how it works so you know the reason why
these [__] shitty corn if a if a if a
guy who was not attractive and a guy who
was very attractive said the same cheesy
pickup line there's going to be two very
different results I need to see a pickup
artist who is oh go yeah then I'll be
more convinced it's called 1010 to $500
a
month so what you want to do is swipe
crazy no I I Okay the reason I'm
bringing this up right is because I want
to play Devil's Advocate right okay
because you think men need it huh we
need this I think Okay I uh I I guess
I've never talked about this before but
you need it huh you needed a pickup
artist in your darkest to hell yeah I
did I um okay so like I think the whole
like epidemic pandemic or whatever of
like the loneliness like especially
lonely men I think I think I think a big
problem is that a lot of guys who let's
say are in the same situation as you
know marrying a DS or getting attracted
to or getting very very addicted to porn
or
getting uh having so much emotional
connection to fictional girls or or like
pay to win there's so so many differents
to offset your loneliness because at the
end of the day it's easier to do that
than it is to learn how to not be lonely
right and there is there was like there
was like literally a book that changed
my life uh and it was called the game by
Neil Strauss okay and it is literally a
book about some like uh uh an author uh
a writer who found himself in the pickup
artist Community uh and I he's done a
lot of like [__] terrible things now
I I don't know what he's done nowadays I
know he he doesn't have the best kind of
like reputation now but at that time
when I was about 16 17 when I discovered
this book um seeing this like story told
about the whole pickup artist community
and uh all the techniques that they use
and everything like that what I got out
of it was at the time I was just a
[__] lonely ass guy who did not know
how to socialize and reading that book
it didn't make me [__] aggressive
towards girls or anything like that it
just gave me some like training wheels
to work with to overcome what kind of
tips do you feel helped you kind of
Concepts uh just kind of like ice
breakers to like how do you open up a
conversation without coming sound creepy
yeah yeah how did you open up a
conversation and not sound like a
complete [__] or a complete creep cuz
I didn't [__] know how to do that
[__] Japan yeah that's the thing
country needs that's the thing and like
I I started off like my university life
kind of like going around this some of
like the things that I had read from
this book not as like a complete Bible
but just as a I don't know what to do in
this situation so let me just follow the
[__] flowchart of social interaction
to see to give me like the training
wheels and then from that after I just
experienced the real world that's what
gave me the training wheels to really
learn how to socialize so like I [__]
empathize with a lot of lonely guys out
there because I was [__] that I I was
that guy you know I did not know how to
go out basic the question then if the
$500 Tinder thing had come out when you
were in that lonely period when you were
167 would you assuming I was rich
assuming you had infinite money glitch
would you have done it [__] no [__]
no it's like pain for PA I'm asking God
I don't know loneliness is [__]
painful
manful that's why I'm asking this
hypothetic hypothetically I would like
to say that if I were let's say rich but
I was is [__] lonely [__] if you
could afford it yeah if I could afford
it I would like to think I was a better
I would be a better man but I've been in
some like I've I've been in some [__]
dark places in my life I cannot hold my
hand on heart say yeah I'm guys I I
would be above this [__] you know I I
would be above all of the [__] things
that we clown on because holy [__] there
is nothing more like depressing than
being starved of human connection you
know and if you have no one to [__]
judge you on your actions what the [__]
are you gonna care about right that's
true that's exactly what this is
marketed when I see a lot of these guys
who get very angry online or very um
what's the word um jaded jaded like
interacting normally with men
approaching women yeah it's like 90% of
the time when I when I see these dudes
who who like feel burnt and I you know
for whatever reason you can see how they
interact with women you're like oh my
God you're just you just approached a
random woman and just started trying to
like you you didn't come into this with
the same level of Interest like you
immediately are way more into this
person than than they are into you and
you got to recognize that energy
difference you got to recognize that
like you're on a different level here
and you one you flat out just shouldn't
approach random people a lot of the time
it doesn't work that's not how life
works you cannot just see someone who's
attractive and approach them sure for
some people it might work occasionally
but most people don't [__] do that
which is why I don't get in Japan the
whole Numa culture what's the what's the
NAA culture NAA it's basically like
pickup artists but in Japan but like you
see if you go to like Sho Shinju any
like big city late at night you'll see
these like pretty young looking dudes
like probably you know in their 20s just
[__] walking up to women and being
like Ona Ona you want to you want to go
hang out you want to go play I'm like no
you [__] creepo like no no woman with
any self-respect is going to be like oh
yes random creepy dude that I have no
idea about I'm going to go along and
[__] hang out with you yeah like and
I'm like I look at these guys like and
they're doing it like in inside trains
and like at the train station out in the
street in stores and stuff like that and
I'm like when does that ever work
especially in a country like Japan where
stranger friendliness is close to zero
yeah exact I'm like what are you doing
you're wasting your time and you're
making yourself look like an idiot I
think a lot of dudes don't know when to
quet that's a really really important
thing when you're talking to someone is
knowing when you're like you've clearly
I'm
inconvenience or you've gone too far or
maybe you're making someone slightly
uncomfortable you can tell they're not
interested and that's okay if someone's
not interested in talking to you that is
a human thing that everyone is entitled
to plenty of fish in the sea bro don't
worry this is why people get so annoyed
even if it's like friendship it's like
you are not entitled to someone's
friendship you're not entitled to
someone's time you're not entitled to
someone's capacity emotion for sure and
it gets I get really frustrated when I
see this online when dudes are like oh
that that [__] woman didn't want to
talk to me it's like well yeah she
didn't have to you approached her you
she doesn't know you anything you are
not entitled to this no one is entit and
it is it is a very attractive trait to
be like ah this person is clearly not
vibing with me I'm going to remove
myself from the situation because I'm
clearly not very welcome in the
situation just get out of it and that's
one of the most beneficials you can do
as a human being is being able to read
that energy and being like okay I'm
clearly saving their time and you're
saving your own time I'm clearly like
I'm not I'm done here like this is like
and it's okay you didn't [__] up yeah
it's fine do you don't have to be
friends with everyone you didn't it's
it's not a slide on you you are take it
don't [__] get let your pride get in
the way it's okay to sometimes like not
be in the correct Vibe sure yeah I I I
think I think honestly a lot of a lot of
the example of these guys Unfortunately
they just has they just have not had the
right role model to like teach them what
the boundaries are what's like
acceptable and or like not acceptable
because a lot of people are [__]
lonely but not everyone who's lonely is
also an [__] and doesn't know what
boundaries are right and uh yeah it's
just there a small minority that are
these [__] that yeah unfortunately
it's the most vocal and the ones that
get a lot of attention I mean it's not
just that it's just like there's there's
a lot of [__] you see on especially
like not just like pickup artists but
what like what's the latest thing like
[__] door-to-door salesman and [__]
like that as well wait what do door
salesmen are [__] floating they're
back now on Tik Tok yeah they're back
selling like solar panels or other stuff
and that and like there's dudes who like
do not do not leave the property unless
you have asked eight times at that door
that's harassment yeah absolutely
absolutely [__] yeah these people it's
like they're just like they're like the
the concept is and this happens in
relationships or sales or whatever it is
it's like overwhelm someone to the
extent where they physically they don't
know what else to do other than to Cave
into what you say yeah uh and and that's
like the whole concept behind all of
these whether it be pickups or or
salesman should be so intense so ass
holy that they have they that they're
like they feel the only recourse is to
then agree to whatever is the [__]
you're trying to do like fine fine [__]
it I'll buy your [__] solar panels
[__] off yeah um it's it's insane what
the culture is like it's insane yeah
again probably someone selling a course
on how to S [__] sake why why are there
so many people selling courses cuz
courses it's easy to do courses are a
fantastic way of milking someone for
money you can be like buep one buep two
yeah oh you're nearly at the best club
right now you're nearly at the top tier
it's a it's a trick it's all the time
[__] look at look at religion you
know there's a a very very famous
religion that I won't say we don't want
to get Seas toist but that always does
it that that does this they're like oh
but you need to pay $50,000 for the
reading material it's go to the next
level yeah courses are easy for a lot of
people because you're making a profit
without actually delivering or selling
anything physical they learn from the
best universities at the end of the sell
the books the
$200 the biggest [__] scam of all
time aside from student loads themselves
which is what are you going to do read
another book nope this is the only book
you can read what if we uh can what if
we just pirate the book can you can you
do that so wait were you guys forced to
buy certain textbooks yeah so yeah but I
I got in trouble one time did I tell you
about this I think I might have
mentioned on the podcast I had a I had
my friend bought the book and I asked
for it and I printed off all the sheets
that I was using and I took them into
the exam and they told me I couldn't
have it cuz it wasn't the official book
and I'm like it's the book it's just in
a really shitty format they were like
you have to buy the book and I was like
oh because my course buy the [__]
book my course you were you were to I
think we only maybe had like two
textbooks for the entire 3 and a half
years I was there and if you didn't buy
it they were kind of just like I just go
and buy it eventually but like they
weren't like anal about it they had this
we we did engineering and one of the
most important things of engineering was
the um it was the uh like the thermal
capacity of each material and they they
would they would have a book that they
would release each year with like the
properties of the materials and mainly
it was the thermal capacity it was M um
and every year they would update it and
and I I I I was curious I was like
what's the difference and between two
years it was like three materials have
been slightly updated cuz they better
readings but it was like I don't feel
like this is any bearing on my exam like
I don't think that I should be forced to
buy the new version every year [__] you
buying the new [__] version I didn't
have much money I'm not paying $200 for
a book no [__] way yeah it's pretty
absurd yeah I'm I'm kindy of remembering
how cuz I didn't have to buy one I had
to buy four or five I think
the main one but they they try to get me
to buy other stuff too and I was like
I'm I'm not buying that [__] [__] I fell
for that [__] man and I I use one of
those textbooks I think and the rest um
I kind
of I'm trying to remember how how did I
how did I learn how did I one piece is
great it really taught me a lot about
pirating and being a pirate and I think
that I I found that very useful is such
thing as a good pirate you know I think
that one piece a lot of cor messages
that I took to my university is uh
ah you
know um but don't have Aire is very
bad but uh what was I going to say do
you think you learned [__] in University
I learned what I didn't want to learn
the thing I I I always tell people I'm
like the most valuable thing you can
learn sometimes is learning what you
don't want in life what you you know
categorically you don't want I I
wouldn't have started YouTube if it
wasn't for the stuff I learn at Uni cuz
I learned video editing at Uni well I
didn't learn that I [__] Le to learn
the hard way [__] you
University I'm [__] lucky I learned
it myself [__] Sony Vegas Sony Vegas
and it was all [__] Cod tutorials all
the time we had we had Final Cut and
like we were learning video editing for
one of our courses and that's when I got
interested in making videos what what
did you learn in video
editing well I mean it was basically
just like cut guys well yeah honestly
like it was it was it was it was a great
way to get my foot in the door but like
obviously the rest of the [__] I had to
kind of experiment and learn myself
then like you'd open up final C I'm like
I don't know what theu I'm looking at
it's too much [__] but like I learned
like very simple just like you know cut
uh you know simple effects all that kind
of stuff to like make it look a color
correction all that kind of stuff and
then the rest of it was just like okay
I'll just teach myself I think I learned
how to do exams in University I didn't
learn how to do that I barely passed bro
oh you barely passed dude I think I
think by the end of my uni like I had
like I think I had just passed the bare
minimum to graduate by like six points
or something which was like nothing yeah
and I got that paper I was like I
learned the entire meal deal menu
combination I went through all of it
Tesco Express on our campus I learned
where every Pub was in the
campus yeah I mean I I think every
University student learns that
especially I'll say it I Le the most
valuable thing of all what social life
how to
socialize the most valuable that is true
that is that is true University I mean
like I I was just not social before and
I I think
that I underestimated how doing my job
now and even when I do things that
aren't entertainment and not like
YouTuber but I'm doing like just
straight business talks or trying to
discuss things being able to pick up on
social cues and knowing confidence in
social situations is genuinely an
invaluable thing that you need in life
tot uh and I think University really
kind of gave me the Kickstart to get
there because you you you rock up and
it's like Battle Royale social simulator
like well [__] I got to stop making some
[__] friends or I'm going to be I'm
going to be [__] in this B thrown into
like the deep end of the independency
pool right where you're just like oh
well there's no like teachers there for
you to like you know make friends for
you or like there's no parents always
like hovering behind you or anything
like that that's also important because
that's the last time in life you're
going to get a shared experience with
everyone around you that's true uh after
that no one has shared experiences it's
gone it's the one time where you kind of
get to make friends for Frey you have
this one joining Factor where you can
you can kind of all relate to MH and
that's gone so that it's it you don't
realize it but like it's kind of the
training wheels for being social mhm and
it's really the last chance you have CU
yeah some people don't in high school
but a lot of people don't and that's
that's fine cuz you're worried about
other [__] like how how to [__] spell
English words correctly which I still
didn't figure out um so you know I think
it's it's important to make sure you
learn how to get social skills and for
me that's what university was that's
where what the [__] did we learn in high
school or secondary school I don't know
how exist how exist existing is hard I
found a lot of like the hobbies that I
still was easy back then yeah for me
high school was important cuz I found a
lot of the hobbies that I still hold
dearly to my heart like I think it was
the first step like as you said like
it's kind of the training wheels to
figure out start to figure out okay who
am I exactly you know and then I'm a
[__] DJ a [__] DJ I'm a [__] DJ
baby know it's it's the first time you
really start having some form of
responsibility which is you know grades
come into the question in high school
you don't have any grades really you got
to go to school every day toool and then
now now you're like okay well [__] I got
to about this thing I have to start
actually managing my time you start
learning really Core Concepts and then I
feel like after that they like learning
social skills are being encouraged to do
so is really a side fact a lot of the
time because teachers don't care either
because they're like I don't [__]
care I don't give a [__] about this kid
being social it's not my responsibility
I got to teacher math and then you get
to University you're like oh [__] I have
to learn this for myself now otherwise
I'm going to be lonely yeah yeah I feel
like teachers care even less in
University oh they don't give a [__] at
all it's not their
responsibility their side project on the
research project that they're actually
doing yeah it's like you're the adult
that it's the last adult training wheels
it's like you actually an adult but okay
hold on let's give you three years to
figure it all out don't we don't want
you rush into the world being dumb all
right meanwhile other other kids they go
[__] straight into it I have mad
respect they were able to make that
decision and be like [__] it I want to
work University is like you're an adult
well are you really but no you're an
adult I swear I swear down and then you
go to the adult world and you realize oh
they were [__] lying to me they were
giving me adult easy and then the people
who don't want to do that take a gap you
and like I'm not already yet [__] dude I
thought I had bills figured out in
universities I had like two bills to pay
I was like this [__] is easy bro paying
bills is easy and then nowadays I'm like
oh [__] okay I'm juggling all these
things all right I got to pay all these
bills holy [__] how much is my health
insurance what yeah oh do you know what
I London University I [__] hate
housemates really yes I like housemates
you like housemates I kind of miss not
having a housemate yeah
I suppose I have Sydney I don't really
count
Sydney yeah she is a housemate what you
she's that is a [__] housemate what
no that's different it's different it's
a housemate that you bone sometimes and
you go to dates with all right all right
that's already quite different I think a
lot of housemates did that in my
univers sometimes you bone your house
but this is 247 bone and committ and no
other bone in the lab okay the point is
that I mean you kind of get the same
things that prop up it's a bit different
right because you you know but there are
the same things pop sometimes maybe
maybe Joey you're you're the bad
housemate and you don't do your dishes
maybe Aki has to do them for you you
know what I mean housemates is where I
learned oh not everyone does have the
shame shared experience that was my
first rude awakening to be like I there
is this basic etiquette I thought I was
brought up in in a certain household and
this person doesn't [__] do it and
you either got to teach him and be an
[__] had the wine glass in the
underwear drawer
right there was a fork actually or Fork
yeah maybe you didn't know things as
well was there anything that you didn't
you were like shocked to learn when you
got to University I feel like I'm a good
hous mate I I was that's what they all
say h the only thing I did was take up
freeza space because my that was my
mother taking up all the freezer space
with uh takeway boxes well they probably
thought the same thing they were like
this [__] taking up the freezer
space okay there's a difference between
taking up freezer space and leaving my
[__] fork in your underwear used
underwear drawer okay Jo [__] up yeah
that's [__] up I got pissed off this
one guy used my pizza tray which
admittedly wasn't expensive it was like
a pound but he used my pizza tray to
cook a whole [__] chicken and that it
was just there was just charred bits of
chicken that I could never get off this
pizza tray and I thought what a [__] he
didn't even clean it he left it there
for three days so the chicken was fused
with this tray I got so annoyed cuz I
was like man have you no respect for
other people's property come on man I
just like I I got to a point where I
just realized if I buy milk I need to
drink this as or use this as fast as
possible because it is no matter I gave
up on milk and bread yeah yeah exactly I
had to buy the tiny milks which is a
thing in the UK I love this thing I wish
Japan did this well they kind of do but
it's not the same yeah they have like
they used to have like the two two three
liter big jugs of milk that and they had
the one lit and they had like the the
250 or 300 M little cartons of milk it's
so [__] well Japan has like the 300
mil Cottons but that I I I okay I I hate
the [__] cboard boxes for milk I like
the plastic one the one we had in the UK
I love that those are pretty good so
nice cuz you can also pick it up and see
how much you have left I can you pull it
up UK milk carttons they're so good I I
really really hate the American and
Japanese are we [__] just shouting
out mil cartons now shout out to mil
this one look at this one look at this
one down here yo
below those yeah yeah those on yeah we
had those in Australia as well you guys
learned yeah yeah we taught you right
yeah we we and look the mini one the
mini one the mini One Mini ones yeah
those are the best the mini one this is
my favorite one the the the the bottom
no no no yeah left left left left of
that left of that no no no no yeah
you're so close left left left left it's
Min that one yeah that one that one that
one yeah that one yeah look at that
thing that's a mini one look at it
that's that's a tiny one that's baby one
I love this but bread bread there was no
many bread unfortunately no bread bread
for one person in the UK you know when I
go to America I'm like why does your
bread last 3 weeks yeah what's going on
here cuz in the UK it would last a week
if you're lucky you know day three it's
already like starting to be pretty hard
uh yeah so you know and that's that's
the stuff with the artificial uh stuff
kind of preserving it the really fresh
bread day two is danzo why are we raving
over milc bro cuz what a fantastic
design really I I think we should really
you know encourage designs like this to
be more common place yeah plastic but
I've already given up bro on on micr
Plastics I'm done bro it's already over
for us at least let me enjoy my [__]
milk C me stopping it isn't going to
save the [__] Turtles at this point
Japan they they recycle the milk cotton
or the the the Plastics okay yeah to be
fair like Japan is kind of like
hypocritical in that sense cuz they're
like oh all of the milks are in paper so
that we can recycle them but we're also
going to individually wrap every single
piece of gum in a packet as well [__]
and then what happens to all this
plastic in Japan uh in most places burnt
y so fantastic yes it's burn made for
electricity but it's still burning it so
I'm like let me have my [__] milk
cotton stop stop wrapping the bananas I
will I will I will I will take not
wrapping bananas for milk cotton like
this you want to get rid of the wrapping
of the bananas I don't need a plastic
enclosure for the B Oh I thought you
meant like the skin no what the heck
unskinned bananas they plastic bag
bananas here I don't want that unpeeled
bananas they selling unpeeled bananas
now what I think I was a good housemate
though other than my incessant shouting
um but that's a pretty big bad one so
yeah that's that that would piss me off
if I was waking up for if I was hung
over and I just
heard I want to I'm ask my old house
I'll be I'm going to ask right now
hopefully hopefully she replies I'll be
like what was I what was the the strong
points and bad points was
I my hello yeah I only had housemates uh
like what 3 months maybe when I first
moved to Japan but that's because when I
first moved to Japan I didn't have like
my own place and it was a lot harder to
like get your own place before moving to
the country right so I moved in with a
friend of mine two friends of mine uh
which I'm sure if you know history of my
channel you know who they are but um
yeah uh I didn't like it I I I realized
I was like 3 months was more than enough
to be like oh I don't like housemates
even if you have friends you don't
necessarily get along well with them
when you're living together constantly
also beats that no other feeling than
going downstairs at like 9:00 p.m.
they're chilling you're like what are
you watching like Lord of the Rings I'm
halfway through it I'm like oh I'm in oh
yeah I had moments like that too [__]
yeah I had moments like that too but I
was also just kind of like oh you know
what I kind of like my own privacy
sometimes and like just having your own
room is that's that's the big difference
because I'm I was never that guy who
just saw people watching a film and was
just like oh yeah I'll join because to
me I was always in the mood of I'm not
really in the mood to watch this right
now maybe I'll watch it some other time
I had arat to play like I I would rather
do that you guys just don't want to be
social that's what I'm hearing I do want
to be social social on your parameters I
want to be social Yes actually yes it's
called being an introvert I want to be
social when I'm ready to be social I'm
never going to say no to Lord of the
Rings especially if my boy's watching it
I'm like all right okay come on let's
get watch I just like you tell me if I
wasn't like if if you walk downstairs TR
off I'm watching Lord of the Rings I'm
halfway through it wait which one of you
hasn't watched Lord of the Rings [__]
you I knew it was well we did we did
watch Lord of the Rings we have now
watched we did this in Hawaii one we
someone put Lord of the Rings on one of
the hotel rooms and we all just stopped
and started watching oh yeah we watch
Return of the King yeah I'm going to be
real if if I had my own room I probably
would have [__] off yeah it was in
God's room we all went to G room for
some reason and then I was because we
were going to have drinks and you put
rings and I'm like well guys by the way
this is the third movie and I haven't
watched either one of the re like the
previous ones and you guys were like
don't care bro we going go that's right
we all met in dance room and I put on TV
and I was fing through chance I saw Lord
of the Rings and then we all were like
five of us we like let's hang out let's
just watch lot of the r i mean like bang
a movie I was like guys I haven't seen
that and you like well the G there's
never a bad time to watch lot of the
Rings I think I think even watching them
out of order is okay because they just
start bang a movies in order out are
they is that a take we were like who joh
wi like John Wick right no exactly like
John Wick actually yeah the Rings stands
the test the time G point being I'm sure
it does I'm sure it does I was a great
housemate generally I was a fantastic I
just don't believe people who say that
you know dude I I I cleaned the most
which I feel is the the hardest part of
being a housemate oh I I cleaned the
most as well um um did you clean of
course I did yeah did you have a
cleaning rotor no no I was the [__]
maid of the house bro I don't believe it
I don't
buy we're we're in a [__] True Crime
investigation now I heard that stutter
in The Voice
yeah I got
clean JS pauses right now what we have
here is a man who just got caught in a
lie notice that his eyes looked up to
the left inciting that he might have
potentially lied when you play La Noah
once the detective will now realize this
lie and continue the line of
Investigation in this direction so Joey
we know you didn't clean you can you
like we have the evidence right you can
we know you didn't clean we saw the
crime scene we we have we have the
roommate's testimony right here oh
really in the other room they ratted you
out it'll be easy on you just to uh
admit now we have an anonymous tip from
someone Joey we can help you out if you
just confess if you just tell us you
didn't clean that much we can do we can
help you out no I did actually clean
though how do you okay what do you look
for what would you look for in a good
roommate then aside from obviously
companionship because hopefully you're
living with people that you like which
is the bare minimum of what you would
hope for in a good roommate
um I mean honestly if your if your
roommates kind of in the same friend
group as you it's chill cuz you can all
just hang out and then when you go out
they can join you it's just Good Vibes
it's just what okay one one one other
thing as well which is an unfortunate
reality I've never been in a flat where
you know if it was like more than five
people there would always be some kind
of drama around some bills getting paid
and I think that
was and I think that is the [__]
massive thing where that is like the
Friendship Ender of like how okay you
can get along perfectly well with
someone you you can [__] chill with
them but as soon as this kind of like
Financial respon speak responsibility
comes into play that is what I found to
be friendship Enders not for just people
that I had red with in the past but from
what I've heard from people around me as
well um cuz unfortunately some people
are just
really [__] irresponsible and I think
being roomates with someone is a big
tell about you can are you cool with
someone you can be totally cool with
someone but they can also just be a
completely like irresponsible person in
some things that now is affecting your
life I think that's the I think you just
described why content creator houses
just don't work out in the long run
either right because like I feel the
same phenomenon happens where it's like
oh I really like this other person I
like making content with them I I
respect them as a Creator blah blah blah
but it's very different living with that
person where you see everything else
right and they might not be as like
mature or right in the head as they make
themselves out to be on camera and bunch
OS in a room and get a bunch of os in a
room and then yeah it all [__]
crumbles apart you know yeah yeah uh I
mean I think it was my University and I
think even more so my London experience
cuz London fled London Shar flats and
houses are was such an awful [__] me
that I was like I think I'm good you had
a horrible experience which I think
easily could Define how you view it I
think that's fair it only takes one man
yeah I think it takes just one bad
neighbor or one bad roommate to be like
I'm [__] done [__] this I'm I'm I'm
[__] I'm [__] done I'm only living
with my life partner and uh that's
that's pretty much it for roommates yeah
um though you figured it out man you
crack though I do like to have fun with
the boys just not always living with
them constantly but you know maybe some
people do actually like roommates it is
kind of scary like every time we go to
America like how many like especially
creators ask like oh so do you guys like
live in a
house
yeah what scares me more isn't how many
creators live in a house it's how big
some of the content houses are well a of
them fail I know a lot of them are
destined to fail almost cuz you just
can't have that many egos in in one
building I mean even with some creatures
like I'm totally chill with it's not
even about egos but when you have
[__] nine people in a house I'm like
that's this is that's a party this is
too much this is too many people that I
am constantly around even if I'm totally
chill with everyone here um and that's
too much to manage for me yeah but hey
in [__] in a in a city like La in a
city in a major city like New York
sometimes you just have to room with
someone yeah uh and I think I learned
early on that I guess it's just worth
moving out uh to find someone more
affordable if only you could afford it
though and that's why people are doomed
in this day and age this really has been
a Duma podcast hasn't it it's been a
Duma podcast as equ what a way what a
way to end the year all we've talked
about this podcast to end the year of
2023 off is talk about fetishes uh doom
and over stimulation let's talk about
something nice to end this year off
before we call it today swag money
what's what's the what's what's the best
thing that happened to you guys this
year let's let's let's have some
positivity to end things off
[Laughter]
hemorrhoids you're gonna get hemorrhoid
got you got to get the hemorrhoids man
there's GNA be an arc on trash tast has
got hemorrhoids the hemorrhoids Arc I
still I still do not have hemorrhoids
hemorrhoid
Jack G have hemorrhoid yet can can gig
beat beat hemorrhoids it's like a
coughing coughing baby versus hydrogen
bomb hemorrhoids versus
gig which one's which we'll never tell
uh what is the best thing that happened
this year this year's kind of been a
blur I don't know about done so much
right so it's like like kind of hard to
I will say I mean you had your taiw yeah
oh yeah that was this year that was
January holy [__] okay you guys got to
experience my home country yeah we saw
Thailand [__] that was so much fun I'm
still salty about the partai that you
paid for I'm salty after I heard about
it it wasn't wasn't bad though I
definitely could have had better though
you guys came to Australia as well right
yeah I [__] love Australia yeah um
and we and we went to Wales for the
Europe tour so we all visited each
other's home countries this year well we
we went to CI cff it's not really Wales
it's I mean you guys went to Melbourne
it's you know you know my favorite um my
favorite memory from Cardiff is when we
went to the castle Yeah and we met that
Welsh guy who seemed oddly proud of how
many times standing in the in front of
the castle this this this talk I was
like oddly proud of how many times this
Castle had been taken over and stormed
and and he's like it's still standing
there yeah it's that whales is just that
Goku meme where is on fire and smiling
like that is Wales cuz it's like hey we
we always get [__] but we never
leave CU I think you know around them at
that period there was a lot of countries
that got taken over especially in Europe
right and whales the one that was like
no we we lose but we're staying and they
just kept getting [__] from Millennia
and they were like we're still here what
do you
want damn it was pretty funny just how
excited he was cuz like he found out we
were doing the show in C and he was like
oh next time you should do a show in the
castle and I'm like what it could fit
like 60 people in there like yeah be
great it would be fun to do a show in a
castle um or just anything in the castle
castle is just cool let's [__] in the
castle uh I don't know what else I mean
we did so much traveling this year and a
lot of new countries as well which was
always hype know I just had a lot of fun
you know doing all the cool streaming
stuff this year probably was highlight
for me doing all that fun crazy project
that I've been working on the year
before yeah was the charity auction was
a huge hype for me that was amazing yeah
that was really I genuinely like it's
been such a blurry year that I was like
was that yester year or was that last
year this year June we're getting to
that point no I I swear to God sometime
I don't know if years are just getting
longer for everyone or if just 3 months
feels like getting
shorter they're getting shorter right
cuz 2023 felt like it went by like like
that for me but also 3 months ago feels
like a year ago for me almost that's
because we're doing it bunch of [__] G 3
months ago we were like on tour yeah not
even 2 months
ago it was October bro [__] no sorry no
you're right it was sep it was 3 months
it was 3 months it was three months yeah
I felt like a year ago man I just I mean
the US tour was a year ago yeah that's
true which feels like 5 years that feels
like 5 years ago I don't know our year
is getting longer or shorter I don't
know but this year felt it kind of felt
like a blur but it also felt
I don't there was no good games this
year okay no good anime
either there there's no good anime no
good games it was all of blood no no
games this year there was no games just
none I your thought funny I trying to
think well maybe Connor if you played
borders Gate 3 not the [__] sua game
game of the year you'd uh you'd think
that
were good games I mean there were good
games this year cuz honai
star it was a weird year it felt like a
year of continuation I think that was
the theme of this year yeah in many
senses it just felt like an extension to
the years prior of almost like
recovering from Co yeah in a way it was
kind of just like people weren't really
figuring out exactly how to get back
into the swing of things because we had
just come out of the whole Co thing that
was last year though no but like it kind
of ended early I feel like it's still
going like people are still mentally
readjusting from that whole period
people are like oh man it's we were
locked up for so long how do we like
life again well you know what the kanji
of the year was for Japan every year
they have a kanji that symbolizes the
year was it it was tax this
year uh for all the tax hikes this year
so tax was the Ki of the year I'm not
kidding tax was the Ki of the year what
because [__] people obvious like
[__] raising the tax on us this
year yeah um is that serious yeah look
it up
last year last year you know what it was
what
war no it was fight it was war the year
before correct uh was it War the year
before MIT oh no so 2020 was mits which
means uh to stay close because of Co
right 2021 was king or gold because of
the Olympics oh right uh yeah 2022 was
IA which means war myad fight two and
2023 was there which is
tax
people is there a reason why I believe
it's because of the tax hikes they were
a huge part of Japanese uh kind of meme
culture as well well it's also probably
because during Co like Japan just got
completely [__] up cery of them
writing this kji it's really like a it's
very fun to watch it's like a very very
yeah guy stands on the podium and he's
like the Year this year's kanji is it's
so intense this guy just kind of like
this really old man with this giant
brush writes this beautiful K so Japan
chooses tax country the year amid
concern over cost of living uh has been
chosen as Japan's word of the year in a
reflection of growing public anxiety
over the cost of living and impeding tax
R I feel like they've blown their lad
too early cuz I think it's only going to
get worse they can't four years in a row
tax four years in a
row ta that's what that's what it was in
the housing housing is next year housing
is next year economy the year after that
do you think during the Great sagge was
just tax tax
tax no money to tax well at least uh
Taylor Swift was a person of the year
right yeah next year will be
Swift like ha did you did you did you
hear about her interview that she gave
off the winning person of the year no uh
did she say I was born in
1989 what do this me and they walked off
what is this meme there's this there's
this meme of all of her concerts where
like she starts off every like you know
how like it's a very tropy thing to do
for musicians to be like say some kind
of like thing Taylor Swift in a way
which is just like no disrespect but
it's just so incredibly corny where like
you know she would have like you know
one of her biggest songs is like you you
now made an enemy of every Swifty out
there it's fine I didn't I didn't give a
[__] but like you know uh like you know
the song uh trouble like I knew you were
trouble when you walked in there's this
clip that's been going around Tik Tok of
the way that she introduces that song
and and there so many parodies of it
just being like you know haven't you
ever like been in a situation where
you've met a guy at a party and you just
knew that he was trouble and then the
song starts and it's just like bro come
on like can you can you do it in a way
that's like a little bit more
interesting please like yeah learn from
lady gagar man like do something
interesting with it I think it's it's
almost terrifying to put so much Fame on
one person yeah I can't imagine I mean
that's what she kind of talked about in
her interview which was um yeah it's not
her fault I mean no it's not her fault
at all it's
terrifying it go what I found funny was
you know she was talking about the whole
thing that started with all the beef
that she had with Kanye I'm really happy
for you I'm let you finish but Beyonce
had one of the best videos of all
time like nearly ruined her career yeah
how it nearly ruined her career and then
she ended it on what happened now and
then she ended it on but it's okay trash
always takes itself out or something
along those lines and I was just like
I'm not a I'm not a swiftly I'm not a
tayor fan [__] holy [__] Taylor you
did not need to go that hard how long do
you think she was like cooking that line
she was holding on to that line she's
like is already dead I'm a win person of
the year I'm I'm a I'm holding on to
this line I wish it was I wish that was
I wish it was true though I wish it was
true that trash took itself people trash
people do not take themselves out no TR
persist some of the most persistent
people in fact are trash yeah um that's
just how it goes Kanye still has a fan
base after all the [__] he said yeah man
like insane coping on him people always
on cop but he made
graduation it's my favorite mem I just
it sucks cuz it's like man I I don't
even want to [__] talk about him
because I'm like this guy's a piece of
[__] let's just let let's just let his
him his name become irrelevant but some
people always want to wait give weight
to it because it's like watching a
[__] car crash yeah well at this
point it's more like reality TV that's
what it feels like yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly I mean A A lot of people do the
same with YouTuber drama as well which
has also been spicy this year as well
just don't see them as real people in a
sense right like they just see it as
like a show I mean if you make a [__]
apology video with the ukulele do you
deserve to be seen as a real functioning
human being I think that was genius I
think it was
genius I completely forgot about I'm
just saying that because everyone
remembers the apology nobody remembers
the apology everyone remembers the
ukulele it's genius what a what a MISD
in a sense that was goed yes the drama
itself was the Talk of the Town for the
week but now all I ever think about is
that funny ukulele bit she did and yes
there's drama involved there but I think
that most people just remember it for
the [__] song yeah being absolutely
horrible it was it was it was it was
iconic we're never going to top that as
a human civilization and apology it's
genius I don't know man give YouTubers
time to cook and I think we're going to
I think we're going to find something
new we'll find creative ways I mean
someone needs to write a book like
textbook apology like how to how to
handle it these kind of situations I'm
going to run how to make an apology
video by kah is that isn't that just
called PR which some YouTubers
definitely need in their lives yeah
totally is yeah PR's tough because every
everyone has an opinion and no one's
right A lot of the time mhm sometimes
all you can do is be wrong it's just
being less wrong well it's also in those
kinds of situations right like I feel no
matter
how powerful of a PR team you have it's
just it's there's never a winning
situation like it's always a lose lose
MH you know so it's just like I don't
know man just don't [__] up hopefully
hopefully well all right Gamers enough
about the Swift nonsense what are you
doing next year what's what's on the
agenda what do you think what do you
want to change next year what do you
want to do what's the big thing what's
the big thing are you talking about New
Year's resolution what's your yeah
what's New Year's goals I guess more
than a resolution I want to this year I
I raised
900 900 $950,000 for charity I want I
wanted to raise a million this year well
while I didn't make my gold so I'm going
to do next year still a [__] load of
money bro I'm going to do it next year
easy I want to play more genin next
year my goal for next
year my goal for next year is to start
and finish the trail series before Gone
why can't you guys have good goal
that's a great goal this [__]
terrible why do you get ripped I do I I
don't want to get ripped get ripped no
I'm good man give up Trails no Trails
I'm happy with how I look I do have a
goal next year but it is a secret and I
don't want to say it publicly yet
because I know what happens when you
talk about projects that on my actual
goals I don't want to spoil yeah because
as soon as you say it big bowls next
year I'm getting a third testicle I'm
gonna juice them up I'm massage him
every
day I'm G do ball stretching
techniques my skirt will be down on my
knees bro what's okay give me a
superficial reward just a little thing
okay because you know I think sometimes
it's too easy to get lost in big
accomplishments right we all do this and
we're all guilty of it and it's
something that I think is not helpful
what I think is more helpful is little
things that you want to change next year
what is something small in your life
that you want to improve on next year
that is just a small Improvement on your
daily life that you think will have
better ramifications on your life I want
to spend more time time with friends and
family that's pretty much the change
that I've enacted uh that's why I'm not
doing many convention experi uh like you
know we've talked about this we've doing
less traveling purely for work and that
gives me more time to travel for the
stuff that I value you know yeah I want
to I want to cherish more of like my
private life I think like just kind of
you know spend more time with obviously
Ary but also friends family you know
meet new people go travel you know just
stuff that isn't necessary
in front of camera I guess and like you
know cuz like I feel like I've missed a
lot of that being a YouTuber you know
yeah fair enough yeah same thing
honestly I feel like I haven't
appreciated time uh with with uh close
ones as much trying to balance that time
but it's always tough bouncing time is
tough yeah for sure and I think I think
I got to that point where I want to
focus more on exciting like you know
generic kind of like YouTuber things in
my career I just want to focus more on
like exciting projects
uh that I have you know put a lot of
work and love into creatively
challeng I'm not going to say now uh
just because I as soon as I say it
expectations are going to come and I'm
not going to want to work just let them
cook let the man cook yeah yeah uh but
that's as vague as I am willing to be
about some of the [__] that I've been
working on but uh Hey like with when it
comes to trash taste stuff next year we
do have some pretty nice stuff cooking
taste is changing kind of in 2024 I
think it's safe to say that you know uh
you know when you've been a podcast for
four years nearly now three and a half
how close are we to four near episode
200 May is four years what episode are
we on though 180
something yeah I don't know Jesus that's
a lot you know I think trash we're
nearly four years in now so I like we
have to start being like all right how
do we make this was still fresh to the
audience we're past that honeymoon phase
of the podcast where the first two years
you know we uh everything is all new and
we've got all these stories to talk
about so I think we we we're all
actively trying to think how do we make
Trash taste engaging so we're all still
engaged but also you guys are still
engaged um so I always one thing that I
despise is when people speculate over
like what we're doing on trash taste or
the reason why it's changing and it's
like dude we just ultimately I think we
just we all have our own stuff that we
love doing but trash taste is still like
this this thing that we really want to
make as good as possible of but the end
of the day it is just a and I think
that's to be thee of it like how do we
keep thate alive but also make it new it
exciting I think uh we had a talk uh
about what direction we wanted to take
trash taste in 2024 and I think we we
had you know we only have a limited
amount of time that we have to work with
on there's only so much time that I
think we're all willing or want to put
into trash taste just because it's right
now it's like a good 50/50 split between
trash taste project and personal
projects and I think if there was a
different ratio split I'd probably be
unhappy with one side or the other you
like barely any Trash taste i' I'd feel
like why what the [__] is the point of
doing it if it too much I'd be like I
hate this is the only thing that I can
creatively invest in yeah yeah yeah
exactly um and we had a few options of
different things that we you know could
pursue and I think the thing that we all
wanted to pursue was doing more videos
with each other just not in the Studio
you know and you know like you know
different from just like the regular
just us sitting here talking kind of
thing and uh previously you know we had
called them specials because there would
always be big budgets Big Ideas and you
would only get like a few of them per
year if not [__] one at
most which is fine but I think it also
made it very limiting right yeah made it
very limiting uh so next year we kind of
wanted to put all of spare time we don't
have recording in the podcast into
making more I would like to call it
trash taste outside you know yeah just
like fun little videos kind of giving
you guys more outside stuff I think yeah
it's but but obviously to to do that I
think we have to we have to be in Japan
more which is like the big things I
think we did a lot of Tours we did like
backtack tours which was a lot which a
lot of people were like why are they
[__] touring all the time they
[__] make Stu and I to some extent I
agree I think touring has Tak up a lot
of time it has and energy as well yeah
it's like you you know we had to
pre-record a ton and I think that it in
some senses it may might have hurt the
podcast and other senses I think it
helped us like I I when people ask me
like why I do it why I personally did
touring I always tell them like listen
like as an Entertainer is what we're
supposed to be doing the the most
valuable experience you can get is real
onstage experience having to be
entertaining totally having to like read
the crowd having to like kind of have
that kind of feed totally different
skill set you have to learn as well dude
and I think as an Entertainer it's like
there's no way to improve so rapidly
other than being on stage having a make
jokes try these like sometimes unfunny
jokes sometimes you bomb sometimes you
say a joke that doesn't get any reaction
you say a joke that get amazing reaction
and like having to have that kind of
live feedback is so crucial and have
learning stage presence and learning all
these factors I think I think it made us
all like better entertainers like
watching you know and I definitely like
lit a fire under our asses too like
meeting you guys you know after shows
and stuff and seeing you guys like
physically there like it made us realize
like oh okay like we need we don't want
to disappoint you guys like we want to
obviously like creative
Cheng ourselves as but we also want to
make that we you guys the that you'll be
proud of and you'll enjoy watching uh so
yeah we' enough that [__] well yeah I'm
done done at least I think we pretty
confidently say at least 2024 there
probably won't be a tour no there won't
be a tour okay so we all we might have
some one-off shows in some cities uh I I
will say that anytime we've made the
decision anytime that we are traveling
to a place uh for maybe some kind of
event there is probably going to be some
kind of ulterior motive which is
probably going to be a trash taste
outside a trash taste special that we're
going to be filming there yeah hopefully
I we're really bad at saying things and
committing to them well not I mean not
not in general just with only with
specials really the one thing we can
promise you though is that there will be
more specials in 2024 than 2023 100% we
said that last year and we didn't commit
to it but we I swear to God this year we
actually were this time we're actually
committing to it trust because we are
committing to it because here's a sneak
peek of some of the stuff we've already
filmed using Dignity speedrun of a video
now you H man welcome to the trash taste
make why you looking at us this oh my
god
[__] shrimp salmon pineapple oh God the
yoga
[Music]
wow and also I think one thing that
we're trying to do is give more value to
patrons yeah uh you know right now we
only have the credit at the end which is
fine I think it's fine I think a lot of
patrons don't really they they just want
to support the show and clips and stuff
like that yeah you get early clip but we
actually making exclusive content for
the patreon it's nothing crazy just
chill little things that if you really
enjoy the show you might like sorry but
actually right
nowy
sorry as K said sorry as Conor said
excuse me uh yeah if you guys actually
go over to the patreon now starting from
this month we going to be releasing
weekly videos on patreon uh uploaded at
the same time as we upload each of these
videos uh here on the YouTube channel
just for you guys so you guys over on
the patreon get extra content every
single week of us in fact if you go on
right now then you get a bunch of
content for this month that is fully
available to watch and you can do so by
going to patreon.com trash it supports
Us in making like cool specials and you
know other cool projects outside of just
regular podcasting but also you guys get
to see us do some stuff that you'll
never see or never have seen before
here's a sneak peek of some of the stuff
we filmed on our patreon already play
the clip mudon this wasn't like this in
Double Dash what are you talking about
the C uh yeah we went on there on tour
Joey oh yeah i' does Smash Bros count as
a fighting game bro my fist is so
[__] large this is Anime F don't [__]
the sheet AO play just the way I like it
boys let him
cook you give off Luigi energy Joey what
the [__] does that
me uh [__] God I'm trying to [__]
listen I can do
D's well that's not a word I I think I
think that's a word no it's not a word
to be like completely transparent we do
want to bring more value to the patreon
uh and a lot of that is because of the
plans that we have in 2024 we've already
filmed some specials and one of them and
a few of the ideas that we already have
booked out uh some of the highest budget
that we've ever spent on a video but
that's not going to be every video right
I with that's like the expectations that
I want to set we want to have a mix of
high budget and high kind of like high
quality quality and some videos that are
just more uh that are just more casual
you know that are easier to filmt uh
just more more [__] of us doing things
that are not in the studio that AR just
totally [__] for two hours you know yeah
because I know a lot of people have been
asking for more streams and that's been
a big like talking point and to be
completely transparent one of like the
biggest hardest decisions we had to make
is trash taste after dark started as
complimentary content like that's how it
started right we we kind of like went
live randomly one time yeah and a big
part of after dark was Co just gave us a
lot of [__] time in the country after
dark was completely unplanned yeah yeah
it was it was completely unplanned and
we did a lot lot of fun things with
after dark and I think going going
forward it's going to be the same kind
of feeling where if we do a stream it's
going to be a special event yeah I I
sure a lot of people being like Oh after
dogs [__] it over it's like no no G said
one time that we're not really focusing
on it yeah it'll probably still happen
at some point it just won't be frequent
at all I think that's a healthy way it's
it's it's more like if it if it happens
uh it's just going to be the same kind
of feeling when the first time we went
live with after dark which is just [__]
it we just had some time and we wanted
to go live and that was pretty much it
you know
the channel is currently being used to
show every trash taste episode forever
so if you do want to watch Trash taste
random points with live audience you can
go do that as well twitch as well yeah
so patrons we hope that you're happy
with like the many pieces of content
which you know which are some of them
are just ideas that really did not fit
on other channels Channel yeah playing
Mario Kart or [__] playing you know
Mario party like it just doesn't really
make sense make a whole about yeah cuz
like most of them are just like half an
hour videos or some [__] like that uh
and most of them are just filmed right
after we have some spare time between
recordings you know yeah they're kind of
made with the intent of like you know
after you've watched your weekly trash T
episode then there's just like another
little side thing to like kind of finish
it off you know so yeah yeah like the
important thing is we try to make it not
only manageable for all our plans but
manageable for our mental health as well
so we don't go burnt out yeah ultimately
I think there's a huge value that we
place on on being here consistently
weekly and providing you a show that we
think is good every single week and and
some some weeks it's super easy to do
that and other weeks it's really hard to
do that um but ultimately we all we just
try to give you something weekly we hope
that that's good you enjoy it uh and we
going to try our best to keep doing that
for the next year as well all right and
uh that's pretty much it for this year
in a trash taste 202 look at all these
patrons though
look at all these patrons that signed up
these guys were the ones supporting us
in 2023 in a made go and again if you
would like to support the show into the
new year of 2024 as well as get access
again to the patreon exclusive content
which we will be releasing every single
month then head on over to our patreon
patreon.com trast over there also follow
us on Twitter send us your memes on the
subreddit and if you hate our face
listen to us on Spotify and we will see
you gamers in the brand new year of 2024
all right see you guys bye
[Music]
bye